nous en venons à nos travaux nous sommes
aujourd'hui réunis en application du
cinquième alinéa de l'article 13 de la
Constitution et de la loi organique du
23 juillet 2010 pour entendre Monsieur
le Premier Ministre Jean Castex que le
Président de la République propose de
nommer aux fonctions de président
directeur général de la Régie autonome
des transports parisiens chez le Premier
ministre je vous souhaite la bienvenue
dans notre Commission
concernant la procédure je rappelle que
l'audition aujourd'hui qui est public
sera suivi dans votre par scrutin secret
effectué par rappel nominal et or la
présence de la personne auditionnée
aucune délégation de vote ne sera
possible le dépouillement du scrutin
aura lieu à la suite de l'audition de
Monsieur Jean Castex qui a été entendu
hier par la Commission de l'aménagement
du territoire et du développement
durable
du Sénat je rappelle qu'en application
de notre règlement nous avons nommé un
rapporteur sur cette proposition de
nomination monsieur 20 sentier beau il a
élaboré pour notre commission en
questionnaire qui a préalablement été
envoyé à Monsieur le Premier Ministre
Jean Castex dans les réponses vous aurez
été diffusés chez le Premier ministre
avant de céder la parole à notre
rapporteur je souhaite saluer la
proposition qui est faite de vous nommer
aux fonctions de président directeur de
la RATP cette opérateur devra faire face
dans les années à venir à des échéances
importantes cruciales je dirais je pense
par exemple à l'ouverture à la
concurrence du réseau historique ou aux
Jeux olympiques de 202 2024 Jeux
Olympiques que vous connaissez très bien
regarde votre expérience passée mais
d'autres chantiers sont tout aussi
importants le verdissement de la flotte
le déploiement de la mobilité comme
service le Mas le Grand Paris Express
l'accessibilité du réseau aux personnes
à mobilité réduite ou encore la tension
sur certains effectifs de conducteur et
l'amélioration du dialogue social les
défis ne manquent donc pas monsieur le
Premier ministre nous serons évidemment
très attentifs à vos analyses sur toutes
ces sujets je ne serai pas plus long et
je cède maintenant la parole à notre
rapporteur qui a la parole pour 3
minutes
sur le rapporteur
Monsieur le Premier Ministre cher Jean
monsieur le Président cher Jean-Marc
chers collègues nous sommes réunis ce
matin pour nous prononcer à
l'application de l'article 13 de la
Constitution sur votre nomination
monsieur le Premier ministre à la
fonction de président directeur général
de la région autonome des transports
parisiens plus communément appelé RATP
cette nomination intervient dans un
contexte particulièrement stratégique
pour la RATP la RATP est un effet engagé
depuis plusieurs années dans de
profondes transformations de ce modèle
fait face à des défis majeurs tant à
moyen terme je pense notamment
l'ouverture d'un concurrence prochaine
de son réseau de bus historique au
déploiement du Grand Paris Express et à
l'organisation des Jeux olympiques ou
encore impératif de décarbonation des
transports en Île-de-France les notes
que vous avez transmises à notre
commission témoigne monsieur Premier
ministre de votre connaissance et de
votre conscience fine de ces défis à
venir et des difficultés qu'il vous
faudra lever je souhaite saluer cet
engagement
qui est aujourd'hui le vôtre pour offrir
un service quotidien de haute qualité à
des millions de voyageurs franciliens
perdez-moi permettez-moi de revenir ici
sur certains points spécifiques qui
interroge notre commission vous
soulignez avec beaucoup de transparence
les fortes tensions sociales internes
qui traversent actuellement les RATP
notamment dans le contexte de
l'ouverture la concurrence prochaine et
qui ont pour effet de dégrader
massivement la qualité de service sur
les réseaux de bus parisiens à ce titre
vous rappelez votre attachement
personnel au dialogue social et votre
volonté de continuer à associer
activement le personnel et ses
représentants projets à l'avenir de la
RATP
pour nous vous entendre particulièrement
sur ce point ainsi que les premières
mesures que vous envisageriez de prendre
ou bien de renforcer en réponse aux
tensions actuelles l'ouverture d'un
concurrence constituera plus largement
comme vous le signez un triple défi
social qualitatif et industriel nous
pouvons craindre dans ce contexte une
potentiel dégradation de la qualité de
l'efficacité du service des transports
concernés par l'ouverture à concurrence
à minima durant les premières années
quelle serait révolution quelle serait
vos solutions et vos actions pour
faciliter cette transition au niveau de
RATP enfin et ce sera mon dernier point
je souhaite saluer votre engagement
prioritaire pour faire de la RATP un
acteur majeur de la transition
écologique nous partageons dans cette
commission votre intuition l'air ATP
occupe aujourd'hui une position
stratégique pour favoriser un report
modal massifié vers les transports
collectifs je me permets toutefois de
vous interroger sur vos moyens et vos
leviers d'action réels ou
souhaiteriez-vous aujourd'hui
situeriez-vous aujourd'hui pardon les
investissements prioritaire a opéré pour
renforcer l'attractivité et la
performance des services de transport de
la RATP les défis que vous avez
vous-même souligner sont
incontestablement majeurs il n'a pas
lieu de doter que vous aurez toutes les
qualités personnelles et l'expérience
nécessaire pour y répondre votre
attachement dialogue social et votre
sens de l'intérêt général seront des
atouts indéniables à tête de la RATP et
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'appelle
mes collègues commissaires à vous
apporter leur soutien pleine plat pour
cette nomination je vous remercie merci
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
Premier ministre vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les députés je vous salue avec
beaucoup de plaisir je reviens devant
vous les deux précédents intervenants ne
l'ont pas rappelé mais vous le savez
quelques semaines après avoir été
entendu par votre commission dans le
cadre de
ma désignation à la présidence de
l'Agence de financement des
infrastructures de transport de France
et si je fais mention à ce fait c'est
pas que je doute un seul instant que
vous l'ayez oublié moi je ne l'espère
pas mais c'est parce qu'il me semble que
je vous dois d'abord quelques
explications je dois vous explications à
la présentation nationale sur cette
évolution bon
d'abord je commencerai par le dire par
souligner qu'il y a déjà d'emblé un
chemin de cohérence nous sommes toujours
dans le champ des transports et les
transports publics ou plus exactement
des mobilités surtout surtout mesdames
et messieurs députés depuis
ma venue devant vous c'était à la fin du
mois de juillet il s'est produit un
élément nouveau totalement imprévisible
à l'époque qui elle a démission de la
présidente générale de la RATP un
exercice Catherine Guillois que je
voudrais comme je l'ai fait hier devant
le Sénat d'emblé devant vous saluer à la
fois pour le bilan et l'action qui ont
été les siens à la tête de cette grande
entreprise publique pendant 5 ans on
aura sans doute l'occasion d'y revenir
aussi peut-être pour les raisons
évidemment qu'il ne m'appartient en rien
de commenter puisqu'elles sont d'ordre
personnel et familial qui l'ont conduit
à prendre cette décision mais voilà je
voulais quand même lui rendre hommage et
en tout cas vous rappeler qu'évidemment
cette circonstance n'était pas du tout
prévue n'était pas attendu
lorsque m'a été proposé à l'époque la
présence de l'agence de financeuse
infrastructures transport personne
n'imaginait que RATP se trouverait
vacances bon cet élément est intervenu
et de fait depuis le 1er octobre dernier
donc depuis quelques semaines
guidoir a cessé ses fonctions bon et
c'est dans ce contexte que en effet
monsieur le Président était proposé de
me porter candidat à cette fonction ce
que je vous le dis d'emblée j'ai fait
sans hésiter non je pense que nous
allons y revenir que je sous-estime la
charge des difficultés que le poste en
question le rapporteur les a brièvement
mentionnés
qui qui m'attendent
le président futur quel qu'il soit de
RATP mais vous ne serez peut-être pas
surpris en tout cas pour celles et ceux
qui me connaissent un peu mieux que
c'est pas de nature à me m'arrêter j'ai
dit je vous le rappelle lorsque j'ai mes
fonctions à l'Hôtel Matignon et que j'ai
passé le relais à Madame Elisabeth borne
que je sortais du champ politique mais
que je souhaitais continuer à me rendre
utile pour la nation alors non pas que
j'étais
inutile j'espère à la tête de la jante
de financement des infrastructures de
transport mais disons que les enjeux ne
sont pas les mêmes et comme je le
rappelais d'abord la présidence de
l'agence financement des infrastructures
de transport est un poste non exécutif
il y a une déléguée générale alors que
ce dont nous allons parler ce matin
c'est un poste exécutif opérationnel on
va dire à part entière et puis surtout
s'il fallait donner une différence on va
dire manifeste la fifte comprend en tout
et pour tout 5 salariés et il y en a un
peu plus de 70 000 à la RATP donc je
pense que vous mesurez avec moi
la différence en termes d'enjeux bon
donc disait je n'ai pas hésité parce que
d'abord je l'indiquais il y a un
contexte on va y revenir j'imagine
longuement ce matin difficile
il y a des défis nombreux
et que je pense
qu'il faut quelqu'un d'expérimenter je
le revendique d'emblée devant la
commission et il y a une vision
politique
au sens global du terme pour tenter de
les affronter
la RATP bon c'est une je le dis pour
vous tous
c'est une très belle maison
très belle très beau symbole de notre
pays de notre patrimoine qui va et qui
fait des transports évidemment vous le
savez maintenant au-delà de France
présente dans de dans plusieurs régions
d'abord et dans de nombreux pays
capitale du monde d'ailleurs se
développe c'est un fer de lance il faut
le voir comme ça cette diversification
du savoir-faire français même si nous
aurons là aussi sans doute que m'a
reparlé peut-être faut-il
recentrer un peu sur des objectifs
prioritaires cette politique de
filialisation et de diversification sans
jamais oublier
le cœur de métier
je n'oublie pas que les métiers qui s'y
exercent qui sont nombreux je crois
qu'il y a ma 174
sont des métiers parfois très difficile
parfois très difficile
confronté à des situations compliquées
je n'oublie pas non plus alors que je
m'occupais avant d'être Premier ministre
de de la mission sur le déconfinement
nous sommes au printemps 2020
que on a on n'a pas fermé
les transports publics les salariés de
la RATP
sont restés sur le sur le pont je vous
rappelle aussi peut-être dans
souvenez-vous ces lignes de bus dédiées
qui en fonctionnait au bénéfice du
personnel soignant pour les amener pour
les conduire au plus fort de la crise et
en particulier au moment où
l'Île-de-France notamment était
confronté
au premier pic épidémique pour amener
donc les les soignants sur leur lieu de
travail
mais vous avez dit il y a une situation
actuelle qui se trouve au carrefour de
très nombreux défis de très nombreux
enjeux dont je vous le dis tout de suite
gélatine conviction que la RATP
est de taille allait surmonter mais
évidemment il va falloir que
collectivement nous nous en donnions les
moyens alors à partir des questions que
vous m'avez posez mais c'est un porteur
et puis celles qui viendront je voudrais
rappeler ces
défis mais bon il y en a d'abord de très
court terme très court terme je suis
auditionné aujourd'hui c'est fixé depuis
un certain temps monsieur le Président
la veille d'un mouvement social
extrêmement important demain
il va affecter le fonctionnement du
service mouvement social lui-même décidé
le deuxième
appel à la grève qui avait été fait dans
ce cadre il y a un certain temps enfin
bon qui illustre les problématiques qui
nous réunissent ce matin
la première évidemment
m'adressant aux usagers précisément
c'est celle de la qualité de la
continuité du service vous avez parlé
tout le monde le voit les usagers le
ressentent elle est particulièrement
importante elles sont particulièrement
importantes ces difficultés sur le
réseau bus ou au mois d'octobre qui
vient à peine de se terminer
25% de l'offre n'a pas pu être réalisé
avec tout ce que ça entraîne de fil
d'attente de difficultés de tous ordres
pour pour les usagers vous avez vu lu
peut-être subi vous-même le fait que
dans le métro en tout cas sur un certain
nombre de lignes il y a aujourd'hui
des difficultés
vous avez vu aussi sans doute l'origine
de ces difficultés liées à des
disponibilités on va dire de personnel
soit que la RATP des problèmes pour
recruter soit qu'il y ait un taux
d'absentéisme plus élevé qu'à
l'accoutumée bon évidemment ça sera
si vous m'accordez votre confiance
évidemment l'un des sujets dont je vais
m'emparer immédiatement dans la mesure
où il impacte la vie quotidienne de
millions de nos concitoyens franciliens
bien sûr mais aussi visiteur touristes
etc bon c'est l'urgence absolue comme je
l'ai fait au Sénat je voudrais rappeler
mais je n'ai pas besoin de le faire mais
le dire quand même devant les
repentances de la nation que vous êtes
et qui vivaient dans vos
circonscriptions que quand même
s'il n'y avait que la RATP qui avait des
problèmes pour recruter ça se saurait je
dis ça parce que tout le monde tombe à
bras raccourcis là sur la RATP
je pense j'ai regardé évidemment les
mesures qui ont été prises qu'elle a
fait ses meilleures efforts
Île-de-France mobilité j'en profite pour
le dire aussi de son côté et il faut ce
qu'il faut faire je l'ai dit de devant
vos colocataires je le redis j'ai
évidemment une des premières personnes
que j'ai appelé c'est Madame Pécresse je
ce sera une des toutes premières
personnes que je rencontre ré si vous
validiez ma nomination il faut très vite
je crois que il faut trouver des
solutions mettre en oeuvre celle qui
agissent en trouver le cas échéant de
nouvelles autour de la table de manière
consensuelle l'usager savoir si ça
relève digne de France mobilité du
niveau de l'offre si le niveau de
l'offre a été pourvu ou pas et donc ça
relève d'un responsabilité de la RATP
pour lui
pardonnez-moi c'est un peu indifférent
et rien ne serait pire en tout cas que
de dire on se renvoie là-bas non les
responsabilités nous devons les assumer
ensemble et un des engagements que je
prends en tout cas des volontés qui est
la mienne si je suis nommé c'est
évidemment de tout faire pour que avec
l'autorité organisatrice
que vous connaissez bien les relations
soit les plus fluides possibles et la
recherche de solution
partagée de façon à répondre à ce
problème immédiat
le deuxième élément le premier rappel
comme je l'ai dit aussi que finalement
la RATP mesdames et je suis député mais
pas unile c'est problème de recrutement
elle les suivit c'est que ça se voit
peut-être encore plus vite qu'ailleurs
je te parle en termes de conséquences
mais elle n'est pas non plus une île
pour ou par rapport à tous les
phénomènes conjoncturels que vous
traitez d'ailleurs dans cette hémicycle
d'abord la facture énergétique appelle
RATP la facture énergétique de la RATP
la RATP consomme 2,5 Tera wattheure par
an d’énergie considérable c'est elle
seule 2% de la consommation énergétique
d’île-de-france bon ben vous avez une
facture électrique
2021210 millions d'euros cette année
elle n'est pas finie mais autour de 265
et l'année prochaine alors ça va
dépendre des sciences du gouvernement
des votes du législateur etc mais enfin
les chiffrages puisque le budget 20 est
en cours de préparation pourrait aussi
aller entre 480 550 millions d'euros
voilà voilà des choses très concrètes
vis-à-vis desquelles il va falloir
se positionner vite et voir avec
l'autorité avec l'autorité organisatrice
avec l'État évidemment quelle solution
peuvent être trouvées de la même façon
c'est tensions inflationnistes on
revient d'ailleurs au conflit social de
demain ont-elles des incidences sur les
questions de négociation salariale
et là encore je rappelle où je porte à
la connaissance de votre commission que
la RATP cela houlette de Catherine Ward
n'est pas resté sans agir il y a eu un
dialogue social à profondique a été
conduit qui a qui a mené à différentes
revalorisations des rémunérations si
bien que les distribunération à la RATP
déjà depuis le début de l'année 2022 en
cours ont progressé de 5,2%
et je constate je le dis dans la
commission avec satisfaction qu'un
effort tout particulier a été fait à la
fois sur les basses salaires et sur les
métiers les plus difficiles je pense en
particulier à la revalorisation des
primes de nuit qui a été acté dans le
cadre d'un acte d'un accord avec les
organisations syndicales je crois au
moins d'avril dernier bon mais voilà des
sujets très concrets immédiat sur
lesquels il va falloir agir et j'ai déjà
dans le prolongement de ce qui était
fait indiquer que la fameuse Nao
obligatoire sur les rémunérations pour
2023 dans le train suivant devrait être
anticipé compte tenu des évolutions de
l'inflation et s'engager dans les jours
on va dire qui suivent ma prise de
fonction SI prise de fonction il y a
alors ça c'est voilà c'est les enjeux
immédiats sur lesquels évidemment je
vais m'impliquer beaucoup
et mais évidemment il y en a bien
d'autres cas cité leur apporteur qui
paraît à horizon un peu plus lointains
qui se peut pas aujourd'hui bien entendu
bon occasion d'y revenir les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques j'y
ajouterai si vous permettez même si
c'est d'ampleur moins de la Coupe du
monde de rugby en 2023 voilà je ne
l'oublie pas personne ici je pense peut
imaginer une seconde que je l'oublie
j'ai lu avec attention tout ce qui s'est
passé au Stade de France il y a quelques
semaines donc il faut que nous en
tirions toutes les conséquences de
manière évidemment partenariale RATP
n'est pas le seul acteur m'a fait je le
dis pour les Jeux Olympiques et
Paralympiques on attend certains jours
un million de visiteurs enfin d'usagers
supplémentaire dans les transports
derrière ça il y a aussi je lisais les
Jeux Olympiques aussi un potentiel de
modernisation c'est à dire tous nos
systèmes biéthiques de réservation etc
il y a des gros problèmes d'amélioration
de modernisation qu'il faut accélérer la
faveur des jeux avec l'idée par exemple
que de façon numérique c'est l'objectif
40 % des billets pris par les fameux
visiteurs dont je viens de parler
puissent l'être de façon dématérialisée
bon donc vous voyez il y a on dit ça
mais on pourrait en parler longtemps et
vous avez raison que je retrouve en fait
monsieur le rapporteur un sujet que
j'avais très largement exploré lorsque
j'étais délégué interministériel il y a
le sujet évidemment majeur de
l'ouverture à la concurrence
évidemment majeur bon qui a commencé je
le rappelle pour tout le monde sauf
qu'il a commencé pour l'instant dans un
périmètre qui n'est pas le périmètre
historique de la RATP je m'appelle le
réseau Optile la grande couronne pour
faire ça ou la RATP était déjà un peu
présente
et où elle a répondu à un certain nombre
d'appels d'offres organisées par
Île-de-France mobilité bon
mais évidemment la grande échéance pour
la RATP c'est son réseau historique de
bus d'abord échéance 1er janvier 2025
ensuite vous le savez viendront le tram
puis le métro
là dessus évidemment ça inquiète
alors il peut avoir des des grands
débats sur le principe même de
l'ouverture à la concurrence bon ça je
veux dire le législateur à trancher bon
mais tout est dans l'art d'exécution
comme d'habitude au-delà des principes
il y a des modalités et ce que je
constate
c'est que le compte n'est pas tout à
fait d'abord parce qu'il y a encore des
textes qui doivent être pris ou adaptés
et ensuite parce que au-delà de l'aspect
normatif et juridique qui a bien entendu
tout le cadre et d'abord le cadre social
bon il y a un bon point je vous donne
mon point de vue qui était celui de
l'ancien Premier ministre puisque c'est
un sujet qui n'est pas nouveau qui
s'appelle le cadre social territorialisé
alors à la fois il suicide des
inquiétudes qu'est-ce qu'il y a dedans
mais au moins il a un objectif qui est
bon qui est de mettre tout le monde à
armes égales parce que sinon si la
concurrence se fait avec des droits
sociaux inégaux le risque soyons clair
c'est le dumping
et que les parts de marché soient
gagnées par les -10 ans sociaux et ça il
faut à tout prix l'éviter alors la RATP
depuis 2016
se prépare cette ouverture à elle s'est
réorganisée elle a
déjà négocié un certain nombre de sujets
mais ce cadre social par exemple malgré
tous les heures et les heures de
négociation n'a pas débouché sur un
accord
ce qui a conduit après décesseur à
prendre soin pas une mesure unilatérale
qui a été contestée par certaines
organisations syndicales
le juge a désigné une médiation qui est
en cours
et donc voilà ce que va trouver le
nouveau président et il faudra reprendre
le chemin de la négociation dans le
cadre de cette médiation pour essayer
d'aboutir de clarifier de rassurer
c'est un point évidemment essentiel j'en
profite à ce stade même si aucun des
deux précédents intervenants ne l'a
évoqué
j'imagine que ça viendra pour vous
parler de la vie rendu à propos de ma
nomination par la Haute Autorité pour la
transparence à vie publique
pour vous dire juste pourquoi j'en parle
à ce stade
parce que c'est pas pour vous rappeler
que cet avis est un avis de
compatibilité un avis favorable avec une
réserve
le contenu de cette réserve où le
connaissez qui m'interdit de prendre des
initiatives à l'égard des anciens
membres de mon gouvernement qui serait
toujours membre de l'actuel
ce que je voudrais être important en
matière
d'ouverture à la concurrence
c'est-à-dire que tous les autres sujets
notamment ce que j'ai déjà évoqué avant
d'évoquer celui-ci ou ce que je vais
évoquer ensuite ne sont pas concernés
par ces réserves
comme ça n'a pas été bien compris
j'ai demandé au président de la Haute
Autorité par courrier officiel de bien
vouloir me confirmer que cette
interprétation était valide ce qu'il a
fait et je tiens évidemment monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
députés à votre disposition
ce courrier du président Migaud qui
s'est par ailleurs publiquement exprimé
pour confirmer ce que bon donc pour
cette ouverture à concurrence il y a un
avis de la Haute Autorité auquel des
réserves auxquelles je vais bien entendu
me conformer
deux éléments à ce titre pour vous
toutes et vous tous le premier
n'oublions quand même pas c'est que
l'ouverture la concurrence elle est
organisée non pas par le gouvernement et
mes anciens ministres mais par
IDFM et la région
c'est IDFM qui détermine les lots
et cette idée FM qui va choisir les
lauréats de ces différents lots
première chose donc je veux dire sur
l'ouverture à concurrence elle est
essentiellement de la responsabilité des
auteurs mais il y a quand même des
sujets qui peuvent relever d'État j'ai
parlé notamment du cadre réglementaire
dans ce cas là bien entendu sur ce sujet
je me conformerais à la décision de la
Haute autorité et comment faire il se
trouve que il y a un membre du
gouvernement ça tombe bien dans son
portefeuille il y a la RATP des sujets
dont nous parlons c'est Monsieur Béchu
qui ne n'a pas été membre du
gouvernement que j'ai eu l'honneur de
diriger donc je veillerai ce qu'il soit
mon point d'entrée unique sur ces sujets
d'ouverture à la concurrence pour me
conformer aux restrictions ou plutôt
réserves posées par la Haute Autorité
voilà pourquoi je vous en parle ici
parce que ce sujet
concerne l'ouverture
quelque part on peut le comprendre
puisque
intervenant dans le champ concurrentiel
il ne faudrait pas que les potentiels
concurrents de la RATP pensent que je
pourrais en tout cas le raisonnement de
la chatte et
de mes anciennes fonctions auprès de mes
anciens collègues pour favoriser la
ratib mais encore une fois le
décisionnel qui décidera que telle l'eau
relève de la RATP ou d'un de ces
contrats c'est
Île-de-France mobilité le droit est de
ce point de vue là extrêmement clair en
tout cas le chantier d'ouverture à la
concurrence lui va évidemment
occuper beaucoup le futur président de
la RATP ça concerne je vous le rappelle
19000 salariés c'est quand même tout à
fait considérable le chiffre d'affaires
va le périmètre financier c'est 1,5
milliards d'euros si je pars des données
actuelles donc c'est un sujet évidemment
majeur
et puis pour parler des des grands
enjeux de la RATP vous l'avez dit
monsieur
monsieur le rapporteur il y a évidemment
le changement climatique il faut qu'on
s'en dise un mot d'emblée même si
j'imagine que là aussi il y aura des
discussions mais je voulais vous dire
que j'ai là-dessus enfin nous devons
avoir ensemble parce qu'après tout la
RATP c'est une entreprise de la nation
une ambition très forte la première
contribution
de la RATP
au changement climatique c'est qu'elle
conquiert des parts de marché même pas
je parle même pas là de l'ouverture à la
concurrence parce que là le risque c'est
qu'elle perde des lots mais
même à ISO organisation
il faut que de plus en plus de gens
abandonnent la voiture pour prendre des
transports en commun c'est ça notre
enjeu collectif donc pour ça tout se
tient il faut que c'est transforme comme
un fonctionne
tout voilà bon c'est du bon sens que je
vous dis mais fait je vais le dire à
l'envers il faudrait pas que les
difficultés actuelles alors même je le
dis au député ici présent que la RATP
n'a toujours pas retrouvé sauf que
semble-t-il le week-end ces niveaux de
fréquentation d'avant la covid
alors même mais il faudrait pas
connaître
la région l'idée c'est de retrouver le
niveau de l'offre et de repartir de
l'avant par des investissements massifs
je crois là encore être cohérent quand
je suis venu devant vous parlez de la
fift auquel j'étais candidat je n'ai
cessé de dire et de faire lorsque
j'étais Premier ministre à travers le
plan de relance il faut mettre de
l'argent dans l'investissement public
pour les transports et en particulier
pour les transports collectifs et en
particulier pour les transports
collectifs j'y reviendrai dans un
instant si vous voulez bien mais en tout
cas
une fois à tout prix ne pas rater il y a
déjà quelque chose devant nous très
important là il va qui va impacter le
mandat à venir du président de la RATP
quel qu'il soit c'est évidemment
l'ouverture des lignes du Grand Paris
Express on va commencer à la faveur des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques avec le
célèbre ligne 14 en tout cas son
prolongement au nord jusqu'à playel et
au sud jusqu'à l'aéroport d'Orly mais
vous le savez bien il y aura on va on va
augmenter on va pas doubler mais presque
75% le linéaire du métro la RATP est
concerné à beaucoup de titres là aussi
l'exploitation des lignes je vous le
rappelle sera fera l'objet d'un appel
d'offres par la RATP mais la RATP quoi
qu'il en soit doit assurer la
maintenance de ces lignes
la sécurité sur ces lignes et déjà elle
est commettre d'ouvrage de la partie sud
de la ligne 14 et
elle doit bien mesurer elle a commencé
de le faire l'impact sur le réseau
existe de l'ouverture de Céline
nouvelles et notamment
au lieu de raccordement
il y a des travaux de modernisation
considérables à faire et nous devons
repartir de l'avoir et l'investissement
et la clé de tout l'exemple que je donne
souvent
regardé une ligne comme la ligne 1 je
parle les nuance
entièrement automatisé on a un recul
on a un recul et bien cette ligne elle
est les questions d'offre se pose
beaucoup moins c'est une ligne
d'offres les problèmes de ponctualité de
sécurité de prévention du suicide
d'ergonomie d'informations publiques
sont bien meilleurs c'est la voie suivre
et il faudrait pouvoir accélérer sa
revient aux questions de financement
d'Île-de-France mobilité enfin des
sujets structurants que vous connaissez
mais le cap est clair me semble-t-il
pour répondre à ces questions on va
renouveler grâce à Île-de-France
mobilité plus de la moitié dans les 10
ans qui viennent du matériel roulant sur
un certain nombre de lignes bon alors là
c'est pareil meilleure
ergonomie meilleure ponctualité je
parlais du du des enjeux du
développement durable grâce à des
systèmes de freinage que ces nouveaux
matériels vont avoir grâce
à l'abaissement de leur consommation
électrique
on va contribuer à la transition
écologique de façon majeure bon donc
l'investissement c'est vraiment la clé
pour accroître nos parts de marché
l'objectif c'est clair les transports
représentent 31% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre parmi eux la route 94 en
région Île-de-France en particulier
à distance égale on émet 50 fois moins
50 fois moins de CO2
en métro RER tramway en voiture
donc le premier défi le premier enjeu
pour l'équipe qui représente
Île-de-France mobilité la RATP et
j'allais dire et tous les autres acteurs
et j'insiste sur ce point et Messieurs
Je le point précédent c'était
l'ouverture à concurrence et on comprend
qu'il puisse générer des inquiétudes etc
j'ai demandé à ce qu'il y a un
observatoire parce que il faut adresser
le bilan au fil de l'eau qu'est-ce que
ça apporte vraiment concrètement pour
l'usager certains termes de prix mais
également qualité de service là il y a
pas très pragmatique pas une religion
mais vous comprenez bien que ce sujet ne
se pose pas dans les mêmes termes
là où il y a plusieurs intervenants si
le marché croit
que s'il est un attrition
évidemment or nous avons j'ai pas ça
pour la RATP pour la nation et même pas
que pour l'île de France l'impérielle
nécessité
de progresser de faire croire d'abord de
redémarrer puisque encore je le répète
on a perdu depuis la crise covid des
usagers de redémarrer ça c'est vraiment
j'allais dire j'ai parlé des enjeux de
très court terme tout se tient
évidemment mais c'est sans doute l'un
des priorités stratégiques parce que
l'intérêt de l'entreprise rejoint celui
des usagers et celui de la nation de la
même façon puisque le rapporteur a fait
allusion j'appelle l'attention des
députés sur cette très intéressant plan
bus pendant qu'il est lancé hein mais
voilà quelque chose de très intéressant
très intéressant l'objectif est là aussi
tout est dans l'ordre d'exécution
j'avais presque vous dire si déjà le
futur président
quelles sont vos objectifs alors il faut
écraser les objectifs si déjà je pouvais
dire tout ce qu'on a si on réussit à les
mettre à l'oeuvre plutôt que de se
glorifier d'en faire des nouveaux ce
serait déjà pas mal le plan bus 2025
Madame et Monsieur et députés il a une
cible fin 2026 on va dire 2027 pour le
PV
plus de bus diesel
sur le réseau RATP 50%
électrique et 50% en biométhane
c'est considérable vous mesurez bien
toutes et tous l'impact en termes de
contribution et de d'émissions au gaz à
effet de serre pour l'instant il y a
bien sûr beaucoup de difficultés
vraiment fait ça on est déjà quand même
au moment où je parle devant vous
à 57% de la cible
encore du chemin et chacun sait quand le
général les derniers kilomètres sont un
petit peu plus compliqués que les
premiers bon ça c'est c'est pour moi
mais
il faut à tout prix atteindre cet
objectif parce que ça c'est concret
évidemment ces sommes investissements
considérables supportés encore une fois
il faut le dire par
IDFM mais
je pense que c'est le chemin qui est
tracé
alors pour terminer ce propos
introductif ce président un mot sur la
méthode
d'abord je crois qu'il faut comme je
l'ai dit au Sénat faire ce qu'on sait
faire c'est règle générale faut pas
chercher à changer donc moi ma méthode
bon ben c'est voilà c'est écoute
concertation proximité puis ensuite
décision évidemment
je l'ai déjà dit il faut que je
travaille il faut que la RATP travaille
en parfaite harmonie avec
Île-de-France mobilité donc il peut y
avoir des désaccords des bas normaux
entre une autorité organisatrice un
opérateur mais nous sommes l'opérateur
historique
pour les usagers il peut pas y avoir de
guéguerre donc nous devons avec ma
Pécresse trouver les voies et moyen et
nous serons d'accord évidemment sur
l'essentiel pour atteindre les objectifs
stratégiques que j'ai sommairement
rappelé devant vous
je peux y ajouter aussi un autre grand
opérateur en Île-de-France qu'elle a
SNCF
puisque je rappelle que sur le transit
il y a le fameux RER B on a pas parlé
dans mon propre truc qui ferait beaucoup
de choses des grands objectifs sur le
RER B j'ai été pendant très longtemps un
usager du RER B et j'en connais toutes
les saveurs bon et vous savez qu'il est
exploité je parlais tout à l'heure là de
des incidents au Stade de France il y
avait un jour de grève donc il y avait
rupture de charge à la gare du Nord au
nord par la SNCF au sud par la RATP là
aussi voilà il faut faire en sorte que
les usagers ne soient pas les victimes
collatérales d'une organisation qui
historique qui est assez fondement sans
doute mais il faut travailler et il faut
que les enjeux de pouvoir de chacun
c'est de le pas aux enjeux d'efficacité
et de services publics toujours
évidemment dans la même ligne c'est le
dialogue social
c'est une entreprise évidemment marquée
par une tradition des aides sociales par
des organisations
syndicales
fortes bon c'est quelque chose qui non
seulement ne m'a pas comme une
contrainte mais j'ai toujours vous le
savez
considéré que le dialogue social
dialogue avec les corps intermédiaires
étaient absolument indispensables c'est
pas simple c'est exigeant mais on ne
voilà il faut se donner les moyens
d'avoir un dialogue social de qualité je
rappelle qu'il existe bien sûr il y a
demain une grève qui s'annonce
extrêmement suivie me dit me disait
dirigeants actuels de la RATP
n'oubliez pas quand même que on a des
chiffres de taux de conflictualité comme
on dit qui
ne sont pas ce qu'ils furent il y a
quelques décennies passées et que sur
tous les accords d'entreprise sont de
multiples sujets sont vivaces il y en a
déjà
presque une bonne dizaine qui ont été
conclus depuis le début de l'année 2022
donc il faut absolument approfondir ça
et continuer sur cette voie je voudrais
aussi penser aux usagers
il y a des usagers RATP vers maison moi
organisés que les organisations
syndicales mais je vais essayer terme
d'un premier diagnostic de voir comment
encore davantage approfondir le lien
avec eux et puis en interne je l'ai dit
Catherine Gillouard a déjà conduit une
réorganisation extrêmement importante
notamment pour faire face aux défis de
l'ouverture à la concurrence
je suis un grand partisan de la
déconcentration des responsabilités
c'est impératif c'est une boîte qui
aujourd'hui dépasse les 70 000 salariés
il faut tout prix que la ligne
hiérarchique la chaîne hiérarchique soit
pleinement investi je veux dire je ne
préjuge en rien à ce que vous dites vous
avez devant vous un candidat pas
quelqu'un qui connaît intimement la
boîte pour vous donner des certitudes
faut-il d'ailleurs jamais en avoir mais
en tout cas une conviction un principe
il faut que le management à tous les
étages puissent être valorisés par tout
moyen et c'est absolument indispensable
dans le cadre notamment de structure
importante
j'ai dit ma priorité ce sera le cœur de
métier la vie quotidienne j'ai parlé la
ponctualité j'ai longuement développé au
Sénat je peux pas faire les mêmes
auditions les questions de sécurité les
questions de propreté les questions
d'information les questions de
convivialité j'ai demandé combien il y a
de personnels RATP en dehors de ça qui
font des des contrôles bien entendu des
machines c'est là qui sont dans les
stations qui sont et qui font de
l'humain la relation humaine d'accord
comment concilier le grand défi
billettique et numérique il faut surtout
pas reculer là-dessus il faut même
accélérer mais on va redéployer les
moyens que cette productivité gagnée
doit nous faire économiser vers le
terrain vers la relation humaine vers le
client usager
là c'est vraiment un de mes objectifs il
y a déjà plusieurs milliers d'agents
RATP qui sont dans les gars dans les
stations bon et il faut voir comment ils
sont répartis et si on peut encore faire
mieux ou d'avance
bref
c'est un sujet majeur il y aurait
beaucoup de choses à dire monsieur
paysan je pense je termine là-dessus
avoir une certaine expérience à faire
valoir pour relever tous ces défis je
pense qu'il faut une vision transversale
je le dis devant des députés
pardonne vous le dire mais le fait
d'avoir fait de la politique alors on
est d'accord ou pas qu'on soit fait ça
c'est la démocratie ne m'a pas être
handicap n'ayons pas honte de voilà une
autre façon de s'occuper des autres mais
c'est l'intérêt général qui est encore
je suis de ceux qui ont toujours cru que
le service public
doit rester le service public tout en
n'ayant pas à craindre les mots ni
concurrence ni efficient ni
compétitivité pas des gros mots
simplement il faut que ça ne doit pas
être au détriment de l'accomplissement
des missions et des valeurs
fondamentales du service public bon
au vu de tout ça je présente monsieur le
rapporteur c'est vrai que je
suis très enthousiaste je suis lucide
rassurez-vous je vois bien la somme
depuis si par hasard je l'avais oublié
on me le rappelle tous les jours la
somme des difficultés qui sont vraiment
mais de ce point de vue là on est tous
fait pareil c'est c'est justement c'est
difficile qu'il faut y aller
c'est justement parce que c'est
difficile ouais bon je pourrais rester
sur mon statut d'ancien Premier ministre
sûr que la fille par exemple c'est
moins d'exposition comme on dit oui mais
bon
le devoir est d'aller là où il y a un
enjeu fort pour nos concitoyens me
semble-t-il c'est l'objet même de ce que
nous sommes censés devoir faire je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le Premier ministre nous
allons désormais laisser la place aux
orateurs de groupe j'ai un certain
nombre de collègues qui m'envoient des
messages pour savoir à quelle heure nous
allons voter donc nous avons pour
objectif de voter entre 11h30 et 11h45
mais il est important que vous puissiez
poser toutes les questions bien entendu
voilà pour le groupe Renaissance la
parole est à David Valence
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre il y a 105 jours le 27
juillet vous étiez devant notre
commission et votre nomination à la
présidence de l'Agence de financement
des infrastructures de transport il y
avait été validé nul ne pouvait imaginer
alors que le premier septembre Madame
Catherine guyouard président directrice
générale de la RATP déciderait de
démissionner le président de la
République vous propose aujourd'hui pour
lui succéder il faudra il est vrai des
qualités signalées pour réussir dans
cette mission à la tête d'une entreprise
symbole de l'excellence française en
matière de transport vous avez été
délégué interministériel à
l'organisation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques vous savez le défi qu'il
représente avec la Coupe du monde de
rugby pour les transports franciliens
vous êtes en outre un fin connaisseur
des sujets d'infrastructures or la RATP
sera le gestionnaire des 200 km des
voies nouvelles du Grand Paris Express
ouverte au circulation et à la
concurrence entre 2024 et 2030 c'est un
réseau presque comparable en étendu à
celui de l'actuel métro parisien
l'ouverture à la concurrence est une
autre un autre défi et je souhaiterais
en particulier que vous reveniez devant
nous en détail sur la manière dont vous
voyez à l'avenir l'articulation entre le
cœur de métier de la RATP et les
activités de RATP en France à
Boulogne-sur-Mer ou Charleville-Mézières
par exemple et à l'étranger à Florence à
Alger ou aux États-Unis ou RATP est très
présente monsieur le Premier ministre il
vous définissez vous-même comme un
gaulliste social il faudra beaucoup de
passion du service public de sens du
dialogue social et de goût du projet
pour emmener la RATP et ses salariés
dans les années qui viennent vers ces
nouveaux défis le rapporteur sur votre
nomination c'est là pourtant élue
d'opposition a reconnu que vous
réunissiez toutes les compétences pour
réussir nous sommes très nombreux à le
penser ici à l'avoir encore constaté à
l'instant pour toutes ces raisons les
députés Renaissance et apparentés
voteront favorablement à la nomination
de à votre nomination à la tête de notre
RATP puisqu'elle appartient aux Français
merci chers collègues pour le groupe
rassemblement national la parole est à
Alexandra Masson
merci Monsieur le Premier Ministre 3
millions de personnes empruntent chaque
jour le réseau de bus de la RATP la
région autonome des transports parisiens
mais celle-ci doit faire face à de
graves dysfonctionnements depuis
plusieurs semaines comme vous l'avez
vous-même rappelé à Paris sa petite
couronne 26% des bus escomptés ne
circulent pas dans le métro parisien la
situation n'est pas meilleure la rigueur
était des rames était inférieure de 10%
à 20% à la normale au mois de septembre
ma première question est donc simple
même si vous y avez partiellement
répondu que comptez-vous faire pour
rétablir rapidement un service de
qualité pour les clients de la RATP en
particulier dans la capitale monsieur
Castex le 27 juillet dernier vous étiez
auditionné par notre commission en fin
de recevoir notre travail pour prendre
la présidence de l'Agence de financement
des infrastructures de transport ma
deuxième question va donc concerner
votre job Hopper l'anglicisme utilisé
pour une personne touchée par une
instabilité professionnelle chronique
vous aviez indiqué vouloir agir à la
fuite sur le des termes il y a deux mois
est-ce l'ennui la quête du meilleur
salaire ou la recherche du meilleur
pantouflage qui me motive votre arrivée
à la RATP d'autres souligne votre amour
du ferroviaire ce qui nous fait craindre
que vous ne changiez à nouveau pour la
SNCF prochainement alors que trois mois
avant de prendre la présence de l'affite
vous affirmiez vous-même dans la presse
vouloir aller repeindre vos volets et
votre rempart de dans les Pyrénées vous
avez peut-être d'autres comme vous
l'avez mentionné avant qu'on puisse vous
poser la question la Haute autorité pour
la transparence de la vie publique a
donné son accord à votre arrivée à la
RATP à la condition que vous abstenir de
toutes démarches qu'en 2025 auprès des
anciens ministres de votre gouvernement
nous ne voyons pas comment vous
envisager sérieusement de pouvoir
travailler sur les grands dossiers de
mise en concurrence entre autres vous
l'avez dit la concurrence transport
parisien qui va s'ouvrir les transports
des passagers pour la Coupe du monde de
rugby en 2023 puis les JO de Paris en
2024 et ce vol malgré vos explications
qui ne sont pas convaincantes ni
réaliste dans ces conditions vous
l'aurez compris nous voterons évidemment
pas en faveur de votre nomination merci
chers collègues pour le groupe la France
insoumise du peste la parole est à
Clémence guetter merci Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre c'est juste
un enfer des temps d'attente de 30
minutes pour des bus blindés le RER B
c'est la pire ligne je vais me taper 2
heures de trajet ce matin au lieu de 45
minutes quand j'ai de la chance ces
témoignages évidemment sur la galère
quotidienne dans les transports en
commun en Île-de-France nous les avons
par centaines et je les vis aussi comme
usagère comme certains de mes collègues
les Franciliens sont écrasés dans des
wagons bondés ils sont en retard et ils
souffrent physiquement de leur trajet
quotidien à tel point que les groupes de
gauche au conseil régional ont saisi la
Défenseur des droits sur cette situation
qui dure depuis des mois et dont les
causes sont connues avec l'ouverture à
la concurrence en cours dont vous avez
parlé c'est un financier qui coûte 5
milliards on fait tout pour grappiller
le moindre centime résultat pour les
salariés des conducteurs de bus
travaillent une heure de plus par jour
sans compensation financière les primes
passent à la trappe et les salaires
restent faibles les embauches se font de
moins en moins en CDI et sous statut le
nombre de jours d'arrêt maladie a
quasiment doublé entre 2018 et 2021
quand les dépenses pour l'amélioration
des conditions de travail ont été
divisées par 3 dans la même période le
matériel est défectueux et des bus
prennent feu la RATP doit donc cesser de
maltraiter ces personnels et ses usagers
c'est la raison évidemment de la grève
de demain je dis 10 novembre les
solutions aussi sont connues dans
l'immédiat évidemment il faut dédommager
les usagers et geler le prix du Pass
Navigo un moyen terme il faudrait
annuler cette ouverture à la concurrence
embaucher massivement augmenter les
salaires et cesser de faire passer des
transports pour les riches comme le
Charles de Gaulle express en priorité
par rapport aux lignes du quotidien on
peut douter que ce soit vos priorités à
Matignon vous avez déjà soutenu les
projets routiers ultra polluants et
coupez les fonds de la SNCF vous vous
attaquez maintenant à la RATP main dans
la main avec Madame Pécresse il faut
dire que les 450 000 euros annuels que
toucher votre prédécesseur sont plus
alléchants que les maigres 3500 mensuels
de la FIFA dès lors on sait que vous
n'agirez pas pour mettre un terme à ce
désastre et vous n'aurez ni votre vote
ni notre confiance merci pour le groupe
les républicains la parole est à Antoine
vers Morelle marquez merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier Ministre
je me réjouis de votre présence devant
nous ce matin grâce à la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 les
nominations importantes ne sont plus le
fait du prince mais requiert désormais
l'aval des assemblées et la
représentation nationale et le Parlement
y ont beaucoup gagné vous avez apporté
de nombreux éléments de réponse à nos
questions hier devant nos collègues du
Sénat néanmoins quelques questions du
groupe les républicains à l'Assemblée
nationale restent en suspens la première
et qui nous semble importante dans le
débat sur les retraites qui arrivent en
France concerne votre position en tant
que futur PDG mais aussi en tant
qu'enseigne Premier ministre l'homme qui
se présente devant nous est-il celui de
2020 qui affirmait à la tribune de cette
assemblée que le contexte budgétaire je
cite implique clairement la disparition
des régimes spéciaux notamment ceux des
fonctionnaires de la RATP quel est votre
position personnelle en la matière et
qu'elle sera celle du futur PDG de la
RATP la deuxième question concerne
l'accessibilité des transports en commun
francilien la loi de 2005 entreprises
par Jacques Chirac imposait une mise en
conformité dans des délais contraints
des services publics son article 41
exigeait je cite que dans un délai de 10
ans les services de transport collectifs
devront être accessibles aux personnes
handicapées et à mobilité réduite
plusieurs années après ce délai seuls 3%
des stations de métro à Paris sont
accessibles aux personnes en situation
de handicap alors que les métros de Los
Angeles ou Washington sont 100%
accessibles quel est votre plan en la
matière et enfin la troisième question
concerne la sécurité dans les transports
en commun selon un sondage récent près
de la moitié des usagers redoutent une
agression ou un vol dans le métro ou le
RER quelle mesure comptez-vous prendre
pour sécuriser nos transports en commun
en fonction de la précision de vos
éléments de réponse notre groupe se
positionnera avec bienveillance votre
nomination je vous remercie
merci chers collègues pour le groupe
démocrate modem est indépendant la
parole est à ode Luke merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier ministre
vous avez déjà apporté un certain nombre
de réponses dans le questionnaire qui
vous a été transmis dans votre propos
introductif cependant j'aimerais revenir
sur quelques points tout d'abord
l'attractivité du métier de conducteur
au sein de la RATP et plus largement de
l'entreprise elle-même vous avez indiqué
évoqué des solutions que contient sur
les problèmes de recrutement sur le
climat social sur l'ouverture à la
concurrence sur ce dernier point avant
son départ Catherine Gillouard a partagé
une crainte supplémentaire sur ce sujet
à savoir que cela pourrait remettre en
question l'attachement des salariés à
leur activité ou à leur entreprise et
donc renforcer le défaut d'attractivité
du groupe est-ce pour vous monsieur le
Premier ministre une crainte justifiée
comment renforcer plus largement la
tractivité de la RATP fasse à cette
concurrence qui se profile j'aimerais
revenir également sur les enjeux liés à
la transition écologique et
technologique de l'entreprise
électrification du réseau de bus lutte
contre la pollution colère au sein des
stations nouvelles mobilités logiques
logistique urbaine les enjeux de la
ville de demain sont considérables pour
y répondre a été créé l'année dernière
RATP solution ville avec l'objectif
d'être le partenaire privilégié des
villes intelligentes humaines et
durables la question est donc 5 quelle
place pour la RATP dans la ville de
demain quelle place pour les nouvelles
technologies au sein de l'entreprise je
pense par exemple à l'usage de la vidéo
intelligente enfin je terminerai sur un
sujet qui me qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur et qui a été
évoqué par le précédent orateur à savoir
l'accessibilité des transports pour les
personnes notamment en fauteuil on le
sait les bus parisien et les tramways
sont 100% accessibles ce n'est pas le
cas pour les bus de banlieue et
concernant le métro seule la ligne 14
est accessible pour ces personnes donc
de nombreux progression donc attendus
donc ma dernière question quelles
actions comptez-vous mener pour rendre
nos transports accessibles à tous et
pour conclure sachez que le Mouvement
Démocrate soutient votre candidature
merci
merci chers collègues pour le groupe
socialiste et apparenté la parole est à
Fatiha qui loichi oui merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier Ministre
dans un con c'est dans un contexte
périlleux qui a lieu aujourd'hui votre
nomination la tête de la RATP comme vous
le savez cette dernière se trouve
aujourd'hui dans une situation
particulièrement inquiétante entre
usager exaspéré par les temps d'attente
toujours plus longs et des responsables
syndicaux qui dénoncent de mauvaises
conditions de travail à cela s'ajoute
les Jeux Olympiques et l'enjeu de
l'ouverture à la concurrence le prochain
PDG de la RATP devra donc marcher sur
des œufs votre nomination intervient à
peine trois mois après avoir rejoint la
présidence de la Fife remplaçant
Christophe Béchu
un véritable jeu de chaises musicales
auxquelles nous assistons depuis le
début de cette législature et alors que
nous pensions que cette musique s'était
arrêtée la voilà à nouveau en marche
sans doute sans doute de vos compétences
Monsieur le Premier Ministre cette
nomination nous semble problématique à
plusieurs égards joignons nos doutes à
celle de la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique en effet
d'un point de vue symbolique
ce jeu de chaise musicale nuit au pacte
républicain culture vivant dans l'esprit
de nos concitoyens l'image d'un entre
soi qui distend chaque jour un peu plus
la confiance envers les représentants
politiques d'un point de vue pratique
cela nous interdirait d'entreprendre
vous interdirez pardon d'entreprendre de
nombreuses démarches auprès des anciens
membres de votre gouvernement de votre
cabinet et de des administrations jadis
passait sous votre autorité dans le
cadre de cette ouverture à la
concurrence que vous qualifiez-vous même
auprès du rapporteur de défis majeur
pour
comment dès lors imaginer un PDG de la
réalité qu'il puisse répondre à ce défi
sans contact avec le Premier ministre ou
avec la ministre des Transports le 27
juillet dernier enfin devant cette même
commission vous disiez au sujet de la
FIF avoir accepté avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasme parce que vous acceptez
avec beaucoup d'enthousiasme cette
présidence de de la FIF nous vous
proposons d'y rester en poste donc nous
ne donnerons pas un avis favorable à
votre nomination
et à part et apparentés la parole est à
Xavier
Albertini monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur mes chers collègues
monsieur le Premier ministre dans depuis
la rentrée la RATP est devenu un sujet
récurrent pour les journalistes et pas
seulement des pages locales du Parisien
lundi encore dernier elle faisait
l'objet d'un article dans une dans les
pages oranges du Figaro métro à Paris la
pression monte sur la RATP et la photo
illustrant l'article montre une rame de
métro archi bondée c'est la dimension
nationale caprice la crise de la RATP il
faut dire que la Régie autonome des
transports parisiens c'est 3500 millions
3000 3500000
usagers quotidiens transportés aux
quatre coins de la région capital et que
la moindre nicoche est un effet papillon
et force est de constater que les
Franciliens sont à crans utilisent les
transports est devenu une source d'hyper
stress Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous
apprêtez à prendre la tête des
entreprises françaises les plus
prestigieuses de notre pays mais qui
connaît un groupe trou d'air sur le fond
d'ouverture la concurrence la RATP et le
théâtre d'importants complices sociaux
vous aurez ces tours de tâches de
trouver très rapidement les voies du
dialogue pour que la journée de grève de
demain soit la dernière de l'année vous
aurez aussi la lourde tâche de trouver
les solutions pour établir un trafic à
100% du métro comme des bus dans une
conjoncture de carence aggravée du
personnel formé là où la crise ne
touchait que le réseau de bus il y a
quelques semaines 25% du trafic en moi
elle se répercute désormais sur le
réseau métro il a objectivement un
manque d'anticipation à la RATP par le
passé une mauvaise projection des
besoins postes covid et le manque
d'anticipation d'autant plus inquiétant
que la lourde responsabilité de déployer
comme vous l'avez dit le Grand Paris
Express d'ici les JO 2024 et d'autres
projets importants les défis sont donc
grands pour remettre sur les bons rails
et sans mauvais jeu de mots la RATP la
conjoncture est difficile mais
structures sont solides il fallait à sa
tête une personnalité respectée reconnue
à la fois pour son sens de l'intérêt
général pour être une vraie vision
politique et pour sa tenacité de la
présence de la région d'Île-de-France au
leader syndicaux chacun place beaucoup
d'espoir dans votre méthode de
management éprouvée et votre capacité
d'entraînement c'est suffisant c'est
suffisamment rare pour souligner cet
unanimité c'est pourquoi les élus du
groupe horizon et apparentés de cette
commission vous apporteront sans réserve
leur soutien pour présider la RATP merci
chers collègues pour le groupe
écologisteupes la parole est à Lisa
benuko
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre chers collègues depuis
quelques semaines les rames du métro
parisien sont saturés les quais sont
bondés et les malaises se multiplient en
plus de la ligne 13 qui est l'une des
plus fréquentées au monde les lignes 3 4
6 8 11 12 présente un graphe problème de
régularité la RATP peine aussi depuis la
rentrée à assurer son offre de bus avec
25% de service non fait à Paris et en
petite couronne les difficultés
d'exploitation de la RATP ne viennent
pas de la légère baisse de l'offre
voulue par Île-de-France mobilité la
cause réelle et bien le manque de
conducteur de bus et maintenant de métro
les difficultés de recrutement et les
démissions en masse des conducteurs sont
inédites l'ouverture à la concurrence
qui approche ne motive vraisemblablement
pas les éventuels candidats qui
s'inquiètent du risque de fortes
dégradation des conditions de travail
qui en découleraient aujourd'hui un
conducteur commence déjà avec un salaire
de 1800 euros net en Île-de-France ça
n'attire plus les syndicats demandent
une augmentation de salaire de 300 euros
par mois
parmi les autres causes à l'origine de
ce manque de conducteur les départs en
retraite massif la hausse de
l'absentéisme depuis le covid-19 la
concurrence des autres secteurs en
tension mais aussi sûrement une crise
plus profonde selon Christophe Cabaud le
délégué CGT des conducteurs il n'y a pas
une ligne qui s'en sort correctement il
manque entre 140 et 150 conducteurs de
métro monsieur Castex vous avez évoqué
ces difficultés dans votre propos
liminaire mais qu'envisagez-vous de
mettre en place pour attirer les
nombreux conducteurs qui permettraient
d'assurer un service de qualité à
l'heure où plus que jamais la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique nous
invite à développer les transports en
commun et en améliorer l'efficacité
par ailleurs comment comptez-vous gérer
les gros dossiers liés à ce poste dont
le plus important vous l'avez cité
l'ouverture à la concurrence alors que
la Haute autorité pour la transparence
de la vie publique vous invite à ce
sujet à ne pas entrer en contact avec
vos anciens collègues ministres encore
au gouvernement parmi lesquels le
ministre des Transports Clément bonne
est la première ministre Elisabeth borne
vous l'avez dit vous pourrez échanger
avec Monsieur Béchu c'est bien et
changer directement avec les ministres
directement concernés ça nous semblerait
légèrement plus efficace ces conditions
ne vous permettront vraisemblablement
pas d'exercer l'émission liées à ce
poste correctement et dans ces
conditions les écologistes préféreront
éviter de vous mettre dans une telle
difficulté et votre votre nom émission
démocrate et républicaine la parole est
à uberulfran
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre bonjour
alors madame guetter a relu avec
attention le diagnostic de l'humain qui
est sorti il y a peu de temps sur la
RATP oui vous arrivez en plein orage
social après effectivement
[Musique]
l'initiation de la mise en concurrence
impulsée vous l'avez dit effectivement
par Valérie Pécresse mais qu'en tant que
homme politique d'hier et d'aujourd'hui
vous avez accompagné y compris sur
d'autres moyens de transport majeurs
pour notre pays alors bon la logique on
la connaît elle s'installe
l'Île-de-France a racheté l'ensemble des
moyens de production et à être plus
qu'on prestataire que vous êtes et bien
attiré sur les salaires et les
conditions de travail
ce que ce que vous faites via parce que
fait la RATP via le cadre social territ
mise en oeuvre depuis donc le mois
d'août tout ça ça se décline par la
perte d'acquis sociaux majeur alors
travaille supplémentaire par jour sans
compensation financière suppression de
la prime de 12 euros et des 20 minutes
abondant le temps de travail
supplémentaire en cas de service en deux
vacations
des primes passées à la trappe sur deux
maigres rémunérations et la perspective
donc de perdre à l'année 6 jours de
repos sans compter ce qui vous attend
sur la question des retraites donc moi
ma réflexion elle est simple
[Musique]
c'est là le cœur de l'enjeu parce que on
peut améliorer les conditions de
transport pour les voyagesseurs on peut
avoir un objectif légitime
d'environnement mais d'abord ça passe
par les hommes alors est-ce que vous
êtes prêts à vous remettre autour de la
Dame des négociations pour visiter
sérieusement effectivement
c'est c'est un port sociaux dans
l'entreprise qui sont absolument
dégradés à l'heure actuelle merci chers
collègues pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoires la
parole
est à
Jean-Louis Bricout
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur Monsieur le Premier Ministre
qu'on les collectivement compris
l'ambition que vous souhaitez pouvoir
porter la tête de la RATP relève si l'on
veut synthétiser d'un quintuple défi le
défi d'ouverture la concurrence qui ne
doit se faire à mon sens ni au détriment
de la qualité de service pour les
usagers ni au détriment des enjeux
sociaux en interne le défi du Grand
Paris Express le défi de la gestion des
grands événements comme Paris 2024 le
défi de la monnaie modernisation des
équipements et le déploiement des
services de mobilité connectés le défi
aussi la transition écologique au sein
de de laquelle l'intermodalité constitue
un enjeu stratégique
vous l'avez rappelé et
vous en êtes convaincu au carrefour de
ces grands défis l'air a été fait et
vous à sa tête restez confiant notre
groupe est dans le même état d'esprit
avec quelques réserves sur l'image
renvoyée par votre nomination on attend
de vous bien évidemment d'exceller dans
dans l'écoute la concertation à notre
égard et à l'ensemble des corps
intermédiaires et bien sûr comme vous
vous y êtes engagé respecter les
réserves mentionnées par la haute par la
Haute Autorité notre groupe souhaite
également avoir des compléments
d'information sur deux points le premier
point concerne l'accessibilité des
personnes à mobilité réduite on a
quelques fois le sentiment que dans ce
domaine elle RATP à métaux un métro de
retard vous pourrez le dire comme ça
comment entendez-vous accélérer cette
accessibilité dans le métro et proposer
une vraie inter modalité pour les
déplacements d'un point à un point B
adapté aux personnes concernées je crois
qu'il y a pas pire situation qu'une
rupture d'accessibilité dans un trajet
donc il y a des enjeux autour de de
l'information
et notamment la concertation avec les
autres opérateurs de transport les
personnes à mobilier réutilisent à
mobilité réduite feront-elles l'objet
d'un traitement particulier dans le cas
du déploiement de la masse mobilité
service et le deuxième point concerne
l'accélération de la transition
énergétique et des objectifs de
décarbonate de décarbonation et puis
pour terminer avant de changer de cap
Monsieur le Premier Ministre comment est
évaluez vous votre bilan à la tête de la
fuite merci chers collègues l'ensemble
des orateurs de groupes ont pu
s'exprimer monsieur le Premier je vais
aussi la parole en sachant que nous
avons d'ores et déjà 12 questions de
plus de plus je vous en prie Monsieur le
Premier Ministre
moi je suis je le dis à votre
disposition autant de temps que vous
souhaitez et si on peut pas en fonction
de des horaires que vous avez donné je
répondrai volontiers par écrit à toute
question complémentaire que les membres
de la commission souhaiteraient je le
dis au passage bon je vais tenter de
répondre je reviens sur les sujets que
connexe c'est-à-dire sur le principe
même de ma nomination ce qui est bien
quand même c'est à dire que même ceux
qui s'oppose c'est pour moi l'essentiel
je dois le dire ne semble pas douter en
tout cas de ma compétence c'est quand
même me semble-t-il le premier critère
pour nommer un emploi public je ne sais
pas il faudrait interroger l'opinion
publique pour savoir puisque monsieur
Bricout lui-même employé cette
expression quelle est l'image renvoyée
par ma nomination bon j'espère qu'elle
n'est pas mauvaise mais bon en tout cas
j'entends tout ce que vous dites mais je
veux dire
je le dis pour la repentante du Parti
socialiste je n'ai pas du tout le
sentiment de m'inscrire dans un jeu de
chaise musicale j'ai expliqué pourquoi
enfin moi j'ai toujours eu une appétence
très forte madame la députée pour les
transports toujours pas nouveau j'en
profite pour vous savez
on gagne pas tous les coups c'est normal
j'ai vu candidat c'était dans la presse
à la présence de la SNCF il y a quelques
années
j'ai pas eu le bonheur d'arriver
jusqu'au bout
j'étais candidat en 2019 ça a été d'un
jour l'autre voilà j'ai pas été nommé
aujourd'hui je suis candidat à la RATP
j'espère je vais en tout cas
comme j'ai dit si vous ne m'accordez pas
le le bénéfice de votre suprage au moins
accordez-moi celui de la cohérence je
suis pas dans une recherche de postes où
je sais pas bon il y a quelqu'un ici je
m'en doutais bien évoqué la question des
salaires ou c'est pas moi qui est fixé
le salaire de la RATP voilà je bon c'est
pas c'est pas Madame soyez assurée je
pense que vous connaissez c'est ma
motivation ne se situe pas là
bon ma motivation ne se situe pas là bon
ma motivation c'est de servir le service
public et mon pays c'est pas d'être dans
un jeu la RATP se trouvait être vacan
dans les conditions que chacun a rappelé
on m'a dit est-ce que j'ai pas
j'ai pas voulu moi prendre l'initiative
cardinale ça éveillé une petite lumière
à moi je suis très honnête avec vous
quand ce poste a été mais pourquoi
justement pour la raison que vous avez
dites puis parce que bon voilà je j'ai
j'étais à la fuite je veux dire le matin
à la RATP ne part pas d'une
insatisfaction dans ce que je faisais à
la fille ou ailleurs pas du tout bon
c'est que je pense que il y a des enjeux
encore plus forts et que je peux être
utile vous êtes parfaitement libre et
c'est l'objet même de ce jeu
démocratique comme la rappeler je crois
le le député représentant les
républicains que de Parlement se
prononce cette une bonne innovation mais
en tout cas moi c'est mon intention je
pense que je peux être encore plus utile
je veux dire comme ça à la RATP car la
fille bon donc je le dis pour tout le
monde c'est je pense qu'il faut mettre
ça et comme j'ai dit à vos collègues du
cerf d'habitude je vous invite à faire
ça quand on veut caser ou recaser des
gens ou des amis ça aussi
d'habitude on le fait plutôt dans des
sinécures vous voyez jusqu'au bout je ne
suis pas certain je ne suis pas certain
que ce soit l'objet du poste qui nous
réunit ce matin bon bref toi bon ma
question est pour moi et je croyais bien
que celle-là elle me elle me tarotte
est-ce que je vais être à la hauteur de
la tâche je me suis posé évidemment
mesdames et messieurs les députés la
même question lorsque la proposition m'a
été faite de devenir Premier ministre
cela pose tous en permanence évidemment
bon mais si j'ai pris la décision de me
présenter devant vous c'est encore une
fois j'ai la conviction qu'elle RATP
c'est vraiment un levier très fort
qu'elle a des ressources considérables
et que je peux apporter quelque chose
d'autre sûrement aussi mais bon voilà
quand je reviens encore à la vie d'un
chat TVP bon
les choses sont claires oui ces
circonscrit à la concurrence mais comme
l'ont rappelé deux intervenant c'est pas
le sujet majeur
mais que dit la chattevp
les intéressés et j'en fais partie
j'appliquerai la vie d'ATP mais
excusez-moi mais si j'avais le sentiment
de parler d'un sujet sur les filiales
RATP développement etc vous savez
mesdames et messieurs les députés que ça
s'est beaucoup développé pendant
les dernières décennies pas que sous le
mandat de ma prédécesseur même si elle a
eu un rôle extrêmement actif mais il y a
un moment que la RATP sort de
l'Île-de-France elle a comme qui des
marchés ou des concessions de transport
urbains dans beaucoup de grandes villes
notamment d'ailleurs plutôt à l'ouest du
pays et puis vous l'avez dit dans bien
d'autres pays
je poursuis vrai
c'est votre question cette ce mouvement
sur des bases qui sont les suivantes
d'abord il faut que cette politique de
diversification et de finalisation
soit sur la base de ce que nous savons
faire il y a quelques cohérents
on reste par exemple à l'étranger je
pense qu'il faut aller de plus en plus
vers le métro automatique parce que là
on a un savoir-faire incontestable
incontestable et il faut aussi bien
choisir ces zones vous lisez comme moi
vous avez su profondé mais il y a
quelques pays où nous sommes allés ou
enfin la RATP est et qui se sont révélés
particulièrement compliqué on va dire ça
comme ça
donc oui c'est la même façon je crois
que c'est important du MoDem qui m'a
parlé de RATP solution ville moi ce que
j'aime beaucoup dans ce concept c'est
que une entreprise de transport puis
toujours elle ne fait pas que
transporter déjà c'est le cœur de métier
mais elle restructure un paysage urbain
ou rural si c'est une entreprise de
transport dans le milieu elle
restructure donc que la RATP apporte sa
contribution
à la conception du tissu urbain autour
des gars etc et développe ou propose des
solutions dans ce domaine je crois qu'il
faut encore accélérer de la même façon
la RATP je l'ai déjà dit
et c'est le point commun avec les trois
sujets elle a développé une expertise
sur certains métiers
qu'il faut encore approfondir et vendre
exporter à l'extérieur bon je le dis
aussi pour j'entends là sur le
l'ouverture à la congrange je vais y
revenir mais il faut quand même faire
attention à dire oui on va essayer
d'exporter notre technologie d'exporter
de d'exploiter des bus en Toscane du
métro ici ou là et dire ben oui non mais
chez nous évidemment personne ne pourra
venir ça la base il y a une petite
limite là bon donc je crois qu'en grande
phase qui va réconcilier tout ça ce qui
doit c'est la progression massive des
transports en commun
encore une fois si on en fait moins bon
et la deuxième chose que j'ai dit tu
hier au Sénat c'est pas du tout comment
dire pour atténuer ça mais c'est bien
pour recadrer
il faut travailler c'est marcher nouveau
d'accord mais ne jamais laisser croire
jamais que c'est en quoi que ce soit au
détriment du cœur de métier alors si je
deviens Président Directeur Général RATP
je peux pas expliquer qu'on exploite
très bien
un réseau de transport en commun dans
n'importe quelle ville du monde sous
l'étiquette RATP pas celui
d'Île-de-France
qui va pas bien là Monsieur bon en
raison
ils ont raison bon alors voilà c'est pas
dire ah mais je vais arrêter pas du tout
il faut remettre bien les choses dans le
bon ordre
sur
justement l'ouverture à la à la
concurrence bon
encore une fois moi j'ai dit sur ces
sujets c'est pas une religion faut que
ce soit moyen et que nous veillons à ce
que
à l'arrivée
le résultat soit meilleur qu'au départ
ça ne peut pas être au détriment ni de
la qualité du service ni des conditions
de travail ça ça se mesure et ça
s'observe j'ai mis ce feu hier au Sénat
que ce soit ça a commencé déjà
c'est un peu déjà regardez étirer
quelques enseignements de façon neutre
externe évidemment bon mais
le cadre social territorialisé oui c'est
vrai que ça va amener des nations qui
n'ont pas encore abouti donc je rappelle
que vous avez cité évidemment des
éléments négatifs en tout cas présente
tellement à l'enjeu il y a quand même
14e mois derrière
donc 14e mois notamment on parle des
conducteurs de bus puisque c'est eux qui
sont comme je l'ai dit les premiers
concernés et puis ce cadre social
territorisé il a vocation à s'impliquer
à tous les opérateurs je ne me
les deux comptes à rendre
qu'éventuellement pour la RATP je me dis
mais il y a tous les autres aussi pour
lesquels ce cadre social territorialisé
en tout cas pour les salariés desquels
peut être un progrès bon parce que
évidemment il s'agit d'harmoniser les
conditions de la concurrence bon
mais il y a encore beaucoup de sujets à
régler je l'ai dit
et je comprends du coup que ça
inclinquiète beaucoup donc quand
plusieurs d'entre vous me demandent si
je suis prêt à me réimpliquer là-dedans
je vais revisiter
c'est le premier job du président de
RATP bien sûr ça inquiète tout n'est pas
réglé je vois tout ce qu'il y a dans le
mais en même temps je pars pas battu
d'avance en disant voilà tout ça ne
marchera pas ça va être une catastrophe
non faut se donner les moyens j'ai
besoin on a besoin l'autorité
organisatrice de la concurrence comme
les opérateurs vous voyez que quelqu'un
regarde un peu comment ça se passe
qu'est-ce qu'il faut corriger qu'est-ce
qu'il faut changer en fait très
pragmatique l'objectif la finalité c'est
pas la concurrence elle-même c'est en
quoi le service est-il amélioré et je ne
connais pas de service qui soit
améliorés c'est les usagers ou les
agents y perdent ça ça existe pas
oui il faut faire bouger les choses il
faut améliorer des choses quand là comme
ailleurs bon donc c'est un sujet
évidemment qui va là aussi beaucoup
occuper le futur président bon
je reviens sur question d'accessibilité
qui ont été posées par plusieurs d'entre
vous bon qui est un très ancien sujet
vous le connaissez quelqu'un l'a dit on
est à peu près au clair sur toutes les
lignes de bus de RER
évidemment les nouvelles lignes je pense
à la 14 je pense aux lignes du Grand
Paris Express que nous évoquions tout à
l'heure
seront totalement accessibles et donc il
y a la question du métro historique
déjà n'est ce pas nous avions nourri
l'ambition
lorsque j'étais délégué interministériel
aux Jeux olympiques et paralympiques que
la survenue et l'organisation de cet
événement soit l'occasion de progresser
un peu de mémoire je me trouve à RATP
c'était la ligne 6 et qui avait été
choisi
aérienne en tout cas en grande partie de
son trajet pour être le laboratoire de
de ce que le métro historique soit
concerné pardon en réalité il y a des
deux je parle approfondir ici mais il y
a d'abord un problème financier
considérable ça coûte très cher mais
enfin ça moi qui dit qu'il faut investir
mais
il y a quand même une question
d'investissement et le le deuxième sujet
il y a aussi des questions que je sais
pas si elles ont été réglées depuis mais
par exemple
les autorités de l'État notamment la
brigade de se faire pompiers de Paris
exigeait
que vous ne pouviez pas qu'il était
impossible de mettre un accessibilité
une station ou deux c'était toute la
ligne j'avais observé comme il y avait
aussi des jeux à Marseille que pour le
métro de Marseille les exigences
n'étaient pas les mêmes bon donc là il
faut un peu je passe à du surement
progresser cette affaire mais bon en
tout cas
ce sont des décisions financières ça
renvoie tous les investissements
cela est bien d'autres qui sont devant
nous ça renvoie donc Mesdames et
Messieurs députés un sujet dont vous
aurez forcément à connaître qui sont les
capacités financières d'idfm parce que
ça c'est pas une décision de la RATP
bien sûr nous pouvons contribuer comme
sur tous les investissements sur nos
ressources propres mais ça se décide
dans le cadre du contrat qu'on fait avec
IDFM c'est un contrat ambitieux déjà en
matière d'investissement le plus
ambitieux qu'il n'y ait jamais eu bon il
est en cours on en a pas parlé mais
évidemment un des sujets du futur
président RATP sera déjà d'abord il va
falloir faire un avenant pour les JO
sauf erreur là maintenant avec IDFM et
puis il faut préparer le suivant dans
lequel ces sujets pourraient
progresser faudra peut-être pas tout
d'un coup je crois qu'il faut le faire
progressivement mais c'est un signal
fort parce que évidemment c'est le
regard qu'on porte ces personnes
handicap c'est le symbole de la société
dite inclusive et il faut absolument que
le métro historique puisque c'était
votre question à plusieurs d'entre vous
concours à la réalisation de cet
objectif
s'agissant la réforme des retraites
question qui m'a été posée bon
je ne d'abord je répète que je ne réunie
rien non seulement sur ce que j'ai dit
sur ce sujet si vous permettez ce que
j'aime modestement fait il y avait déjà
eu et j'avais beaucoup négocié avec les
syndicats de la RATP à l'époque une
première réforme des régimes spéciaux
qui portaient sur les bonifications et
la disparition des bonifications c'était
à l'automne 2007
et j'étais à l'époque je le rappelle le
directeur de cabinet de Monsieur
Bertrand et nous avions discuté beaucoup
beaucoup avec tous les syndicats pas que
ceux de la RATP mais la RATP en
particulier puisque c'est le sujet bon
donc nous avions déjà fait une première
avancée sur ce sujet et il y avait bien
entendu des des discussions
sérieuses des conflits sociaux m'a fait
nous avions ensemble abouti donc je ne
c'est votre question je j'assume ce que
j'ai dit bon et bon ceci dit maintenant
là au jour d'aujourd'hui si je suis pas
RATP ma demande c'est pas moi
pardonnez-moi je suis pas comme vous je
suis parti au mois de mai je ne me suis
pas présenté à des élections
législatives je ne suis plus loin de
l'onction du suffrage universel bon
c'est à gouvernement pendant la
République à sa nationale au Sénat de
décider les contours de la forme des
retraites et en particulier celle des
régimes spéciaux puisque c'est votre
question moi ma demande
c'est évidemment d'être consulté quand
même en amont sur les modalités les
conditions de faisabilité et évidemment
quand le moment viendra je n'ai pas
d'informations à vous donner là-dessus
mais de
mener ou de concourir en tout cas on
négociation indispensable et bien je ne
doute pas que ce sera difficile mais
rassurez-vous j'ai bon mais voilà
d'apporter par construction mais c'est
vraiment le rôle ça rejoint d'ailleurs
la question précédente du président de
cette entreprise avec ces équipes qui
sont déjà très impliquées donc voilà
après cette au pouvoir public
démocratiquement désigné
constitutionnellement habilités à donner
le contenu et le top de de ce qui est ou
de ce que serait ou de ce que sera
cette réforme voilà
j'en profite aussi pour évoquer le chef
de la sécurité que je n'ai pas traité ce
matin parce que je l'ai pardonne-moi
beaucoup abordé hier après-midi au Sénat
pour vous dire que
c'est un sujet essentiel plusieurs l'ont
dit aussi d'ailleurs il y a pas que vous
c'est un sujet essentiel
pas simple sur lequel il nous faut faire
des efforts j'ai indiqué hier devant vos
collègues sénateurs que l'une des
premières visites que je ferai sera au
centre de coordination opérationnelle
qui a été ouvert au mois de juillet
dernier sous l'égide du préfet de police
je me déplacerai très vite même si j'ai
l'habitude d'y aller mais pas avec la
casquette de président de la RATP si
vous voulez bien me la donner dans les
stations du nord-est de Paris parce que
c'est là qu'on voit bon en réalité vous
le savez il y a un groupement interne à
la RATP dédié à la sécurité qui comme je
l'ai indiqué à il y a pas que les
chauffeurs de bus pour lesquels on a un
problème de recrutement a aussi des
problèmes de recrutement donc ça veut
dire que les effectifs budgétaires comme
en direct classiquement ne sont pas tous
pourvus
IDFM nous a dit je crois qu'il faudrait
arriver à un millier de ces agents je
crois qu'à la fin de l'année 2022 la fin
d'un an sera plutôt autour de 900 20
donc il faut à tout prix là aussi jusque
avec eux pardon pour voir quelles sont
les obstacles je vois à peu près mais
pour essayer de d'abord connaître les
moyens et puis vous le savez il y a
aussi des questions de coordination avec
à la police nationale avec j'ai vu que
la région voulait elle-même créer un
dispositif de de sécurité bon je veux
pas de commentaires le seul voilà
plus on est mieux c'est a priori mais à
condition que tout ça soit quand même
bien articulé dans la aussi la finalité
c'est l'efficacité mais j'ai
parfaitement conscience pour de
multiples raisons qu'il y a évidemment
un problème de sécurité et dans les
enjeux de quotidienneté la question de
sécurité évidemment est un des éléments
majeurs à prendre en considération
pour
poser la question je crois que c'est
même gaieté bon
je peux pas répondre à tout puisque bon
de toute façon elle m'a dit que son
opinion était déjà faite à la limite
quelle que soit les réponses que je fais
bon mais quand même sur le sur le RER B
juste parce que je crois que vous avez
raison là aussi on voit bien que je vous
le dis parce que vous allez avoir à
reconnaître de tout ça par encore une
fois les décisions qui devront être
prises pour le financement des
infrastructures de transport c'est
toutes les autorités organisatrices en
l'espèce ici des FM il y a un grand
programme qui est prévu pour le RER B
avec notamment le changement le
programme sur les voies des problèmes
d'exploitation et le remplacement de
toutes les rames bon ça va s'étaler dans
le temps mais c'est déjà décidé par
IDFM bon et nous allons nous opérateurs
évidemment mettre à l'oeuvre ses
décisions mais on voit bien que je le
dis parce que souvent mal connu on a
devant nous des investissements très
lourds qui posent le gros problème
d'ailleurs parce que plus vous
investissez sur les voies par exemple et
c'est absolument indispensable pour les
renouveler plus vous gêner enfin plus
vous entraîner des perturbations du
trafic et comme ce secret pour personne
il y a eu des retards d'investissement
pendant plusieurs décennies on les
rattrape maintenant et il faut
poursuivre voire je le répète accroître
et ça génère je pense à partir pas
seulement mais au fait sonore de Paris
le RER B est concerné ça génère des
troubles fin des difficultés de trafic
même si les opérateurs essaient de le
faire le week-end la nuit etc mais des
difficultés trafic qui vont
supposer beaucoup de patience à part des
usagers il faut y aller il faut investir
dans les transports en commun il faut
investir dans les transports la France
est en retards la France est en retard
et l'Île-de-France en particulier mais
pas que
je vois que le président me presse
il y a pas que lui bon allez
merci monsieur le Premier ministre nous
avons donc aux questions question d'une
minute je vous propose de prendre toutes
les questions de sorte à ce que il
puisse y avoir par la suite des réponses
données durant cette commission qui est
pas de réponse écrite
j'en ai Eugies pour une minute
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre l'amélioration de la
qualité de l'air à l'intérieur des
enceintes ferroviaires souterraines
constitue un enjeu du plan national
santé environnement qui a été adopté à
quelques mois selon l'ancêtre depuis le
début des années 2000 des mesures ont
mis en évidence dans les ancêtres
ferroviaires tels que celles du métro
parisien des concentrations en
particulier fines en suspension dans
l'air les PM de 5 PM10 qui sont en
moyenne trois fois plus élevés que dans
l'air extérieur urbain alors face à
cette situation question est simple
c'est quelle démarche volontariste
souhaitez-vous engager pour améliorer la
qualité de l'air donc dans le réseau
souterrain de la de la RATP pour
préserver la santé respiratoire à la
fois des usagers mais aussi de vos
futurs collaborateurs et puisqu'il me
reste quelques secondes et un petit peu
à l'aparté puisque vous avez évoqué la
question la Coupe du monde de rugby
j'espère que si vous prenez la tête de
la RATP l'Artp pour annoncement
accompagner les 15 de France dans leur
victoire mais surtout faire du mécénat
sportif en direction de
du rugby et puis particulièrement
peut-être pour le 15 parlementaire merci
merci chers collègues
la parole est à Daniel brulbois
monsieur le Premier ministre je
souhaiterais vous rassurer nous sommes
persuadés que vous êtes à la hauteur et
que votre image est une chance pour la
RATP enfin c'est ce que nous pensons
très fort dans le Jura Monsieur le
Premier Ministre moi je voudrais vous
demander alors que la balance extérieure
du commerce extérieur de la France est
un sujet et que la RATP est vraiment une
vitrine à l'international de la France
qu'est-ce que vous pensez pouvoir
trouver de nouveaux contrats et on a
toujours à l'esprit la réussite des
contrats avec l'Arabie Saoudite ou le
Qatar avec le métro automatique ou
encore avec les États-Unis et comment
pensez-vous développer cela pour notre
pays
la parole est à Nicolas dragon
si monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre avec tout le respect
qui vous est dû c'est avec surprise
qu'on vous retrouve une nouvelle fois
devant cette commission pour finalement
ce qui apparaît être comme un second
entretien d'embauche en moins de 3 mois
un sans emploi inscrit au Pôle Emploi
aurait-il autant de chance d'être dans
votre cas rien n'est moins sûr toujours
est-il que votre apparition devant cette
commission pour valider votre nomination
à la tête de la RATP troisième opérateur
mondial de transport
pose légitimement question je me posais
la question puisque même dans ma
circonscription dans l'Aisne la RATP est
présente au travers de la RATP Dev or on
ne trouve rien dans votre longue
expérience qui justifie la prise de
direction de cette entreprise qui exige
une implication totale énorme
c'est-à-dire de tous les instants que
confère sa direction ma question est la
suivante quelles sont les garanties
concrètes que vous pouvez apporter
devant cette commission pour la
convaincre de valider votre nomination
cela bien sûr en rapport avec vos
compétences sans doute
ignorer par les millions d'usagers de la
RATP je vous remercie chers
mais que vous avez retiré votre question
je ne vois pas Emmanuel Tachet de la
page non très bien la parole est à Paul
vanille
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre je suis élu du Val
d'Oise d'Argenton et de Bezons et donc
de grandes couronnes et nous subissons
depuis près d'un an les conséquences de
l'ouverture à la concurrence des lignes
de bus monsieur le premier c'est une
catastrophe pour les salariés qui ont vu
leur prime leur salaire diminués qui
voient leurs amplitudes de travail
horaire croître dans des proportions
considérables avec des questions de
sécurité aussi pour les usagers et donc
nous avons des démissions nous avons des
arrêts maladie les bus ne circulent plus
pour les usagers c'est un quotidien qui
est littéralement pourri avec dans ma
circonscription jusqu'à 100 passages
supprimés par jour le jour de la rentrée
scolaire par exemple 20% de bus en moins
donc des retards pour les lycéens pour
les étudiants pour ceux qui travaillent
notamment pour les travailleurs
essentiels qui partent tôt le matin et
qui n'ont pas d'autres moyens de
transport
riche de cette enseignement vous avez
dit ne pas avoir de religion en la
matière ne faut-il pas être prudent et
au moins c'est notre proposition engager
un moratoire sous l'ouverture à la
concurrence dans les transports
franciliens
la parole est Emmanuel Maquet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre les foyers parisiens
sont seulement 33% à posséder une
voiture c'est le taux je crois le plus
bas et c'est grâce à la RATP vous l'avez
rappelé la voiture représente en moyenne
20% des émissions carbone des Français
en permettant de vivre sans voiture dans
une agglomération dans l'agglomération
la plus peuplée du pays la RATP prend
donc un rend donc pas non un service
climatique majeur à la France pourtant
le service vous l'avait dit également
n'est pas au niveau à la fois en termes
de ponctualité de fréquence de propreté
de sécurité le dialogue social tellement
dégradé que les usagers dépités et en
colère ne se demandent plus les raisons
pour lesquelles les grèves arbitraires
font maintenant partie du paysage
Monsieur le Premier Ministre les foyers
qu'il vous faut encore convaincre
d'abandonner la voiture à Paris ce sont
les plus aisés et quand on voit le
niveau de service de RATP on se dit
qu'ils ne seront pas convaincus de sitôt
chaque bus annulé chaque métro bondé
c'est un argument de plus pour les
concessionnaires automobiles ma question
est donc la suivante qu'allez-vous faire
très concrètement pour que les
transports en commun à Paris deviennent
le choix par défaut de tous les
Franciliens merci chers collègues la
parole est à Jean-Pierre tête
c'est le Président chers collègues
Monsieur le Premier Ministre on nous
répète qu'il faut privilégier
effectivement la marche et les
transports en commun alors qu'en réalité
vous l'avez dit un quart de l'offre aux
usagers n'est pas réalisé aujourd'hui
les Ford moins polluées louables mais
pas au détriment et l'exclusion d'une
partie des habitants tout le monde
n'habite pas au centre de Paris et ne
pas se déplacer en vélo ou en
trottinette de plus l'accessibilité
limitée des infrastructures laisse une
partie importante des usagers à l'écart
en effet être contraint à s'entasser
dans des rames bandés peut-être beaucoup
plus usant que rouler en zoo électrique
vous allez devoir travailler avec deux
femmes qui s'opposent Valérie Pécresse à
la région et un Hidalgo à la ville l'une
veut produire une offre correcte et
efficace sans augmenter le prix du Pass
Navigo l'autre fait des travaux pour
entraver la mobilité et met en place des
zones à faible émission comment
apprécez-vous ces futures relations et
quels sont vos propositions pour ne pas
laisser de côté une partie de la
population
la parole est à Jean-Yves Bonnie
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre d'abord merci pour
votre éclairage et votre enthousiasme
concernant votre candidature je vais
faire appel à votre connaissance aiguë
du secteur des transports collectifs et
notamment des nouveaux modes
d'alimentation des carbonées des
véhicules
vous l'avez rappelé dans vos propos la
RATP est très engagé dans la
décarbonation de sa flotte avec le
programme bus 2025 qui prévoit de migrer
l'intégralité de son parc de 4600
véhicules vers une flotte de 100%
écologique 80% électrique et 20% en
biogaz d'après nos informations la
moitié du parc aurait déjà été convertie
en bus propre faisant de la métropole
parisienne une pionnière dans le monde
nous souhaiterions cependant savoir si
cette première expérience de transition
de la flotte de bus a permis à la RATP
de dégager des enseignements utiles
merci
la parole est à Vincent des cœurs
tout aussi concerné que moi par la RATP
je me suis intéressé dans un récent
rapport aux perspectives que peut offrir
l'hydrogène et plus particulièrement
l'hydrogène vert dans la réduction de
l'empreinte carbone des véhicules lourds
la RATP vous l'avez rappelé c'est engagé
dans la décarbonation de sa flotte en
faisant le choix de l'électricité du
biogaz et en affichant l'objectif
ambitieux
d'une migration totale à l'horizon 2026
vous avez pris soin de préciser plutôt
2027 au-delà de ce choix je souhaiterais
savoir si RATP reste ouverte à cette
technologie l'hydrogène si elle est un
acteur où le partenaire de nombreux
travaux entrepris dans le cadre de la
Stratégie nationale sur l'hydrogène et
si son futur président pense qu'elle a
un rôle à jouer dans le déploiement de
cette filière d'avenir dans le monde du
transport ce qui serait bienvenu regarde
la surface de l'entreprise dans les
orientations sont scruter et peuvent
avoir valeur d'exemple la parole est à
Gérard le seul
merci Président je souhaiterais revenir
sur quelques points et poser deux
questions aux fonctionnaires que vous
êtes monsieur Castex tout d'abord au
sujet de la hatv non pas à propos des
avertissements que vous avez rappelé
tout à l'heure ainsi que mes collègues
et qui met en évidence l'extrême
vigilance pour éviter le conflit
d'intérêt pour reprendre vos mots plus
globalement de mon point de vue ça pose
aussi la question de la mise en
application de la loi Sapin et des
déclarations à l'âge atvp ne pensez-vous
pas qu'il serait plus juste pertinent
transparent que tout contact entre le
gouvernement une administration une
entreprise le Parlement soit déclaré
dans le registre de la hatvp et pas
uniquement dans les cas d'intervention
volontaire sur un texte de loi ou une
réglementation et ce quel que soit la
personne qui prend l'initiative de ce
contact ensuite oui tout à fait ensuite
que va-t-il se passer à lafit votre
décision de rejoindre la RATP sans
accréditer les propos de la Cour des
comptes qui considèrent la fuite plutôt
comme une coquille vide alors que vont
devenir les ambitions que vous avez
affiché juillet dernier et en
particulier sur le développement des
transports en commun et du ferroviaire
dont les investissements restent très
largement insuffisants aujourd'hui merci
la parole est à Lisa belluco
merci monsieur le Président d'après les
chiffres de 2019 la publicité sur le
réseau de la RATP c'est 60 000 faces
publicitaires dont 700 écrans le chiffre
d'affaires lié à ce marché de publicité
serait compris entre 130 et 150 millions
d'euros par an j'en conclus que la
publicité fait donc partie intégrante du
modèle économique de la RATP ce service
encore public de transport en commun se
finance en partie via l'agression
publicitaire je voudrais appuyer sur un
sujet en particulier les panneaux
numériques un panneau avec une face
numérique consomme 7 fois plus que le
plus énergivore des mobiliers non
numérique et un panneau avec deux faces
numériques consomment 13 fois plus soit
entre 6800 et 12600 kWh dans le contexte
actuel de crise énergétique et de
sobriété indispensables je vous le
rappelle c'est la fin de l'abondance
serez-vous prêt une fois nommé à la tête
de la RATP à mettre fin au recours à la
publicité numérique sur tout le réseau
de la RATP
la parole est à Jean-Louis donc Guy
Bricout pardon merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur Castex nous vous
auditionnions ici même en juillet
dernier pour votre prise de fonction a
été de la fuite alors que pensez-vous de
cette agence d'État et qu'avez-vous eu
le temps d'y faire c'est une agence
d'État alors je vous avais interpellé
deux reprises quand vous étiez Premier
ministre sur l'utilité des agences
d'État et
dénoncer le grand nombre des gens d'État
en France il y en a 1245 en France il y
en a que 122 en Allemagne elle coûte 60
milliards par an à l'état ça rapporte
qui a été communiqué ça c'est ma
première question et deuxième question à
la Présidente de la Région Île-de-France
vous avez saisi du problème de
financement des transports selon elle il
lui manque 450 millions d'euros pour
boucler son budget comment allez-vous
travailler ces prochains mois sur cette
question cruciale sachant que les
usagers ont cette période de crise
verraient certaine un très mauvais œil
une augmentation du Pass Navigo merci
merci cher collègue enfin pour clôturer
cette série de questions la parole est à
Benjamin sainte-huile merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier Ministre
après la courte nuit des députés votre
énergie matinale et bienvenue
merci beaucoup une question simple parce
que je fais partie de ceux qui ont des
difficultés à émerger j'ai pas bien
compris la stratégie qui serait la vôtre
sur la question des effectifs vous avez
parlé du dialogue social vous avez parlé
des difficultés d'attractivité d'un
certain nombre de métiers de la
complexité des différents métiers qui
existent dans la boutique en quelque
sorte ma question c'est est-ce que vous
êtes au clair est-ce que vous avez
d'ores et déjà fixé une feuille de route
sur les effectifs globaux de la RATP
est-ce que vous avez l'idée de
considérer qu'on regarde l'évolution
technologique on pourrait être amené à
diminuer les effectifs de la RATP ou
est-ce que vous considérez qu'il est
absolument nécessaire à minima de les
maintenir voire de les augmenter si tu
as été le cas dans quel corps de métier
envisagez-vous des recrutements plus
spécifiques merci beaucoup merci chers
collègues avant de laisser la parole à
Monsieur le Premier Ministre est-ce que
tous les collègues ont pu poser leurs
questions il me semble que oui c'est le
premier ministre soin de répondre bon
alors je vais essayer d'aller rapidement
peut-être d'abord des questions liées à
la transition écologique au
développement durable la première
c'était sur la qualité de l'air bon
c'est un vrai sujet là aussi vous avez
trouvé j'essaie d'être cohérent voyez
comme la question des investissements il
répond
en va je vous disais tout à l'heure
IDFM remplacé plus de la moitié dans les
années à venir du matériel roulant à la
RATP par du réseau métro
dans les matériaux dans les voitures qui
ont été commandées qui va être livrés
l'émission des particules qui se produit
à l'occasion du freinage
va être diminué je crois de 10 ou 15%
ce qui aura un impact
fondamental important en tout cas sur la
qualité de l'air bon la difficulté qu'on
a c'est un sujet je vous le dis
prioritaire pour IDFM je le répète aussi
et évidemment pour pour la RATP le sujet
vous le savez c'est que il existe pas de
normes sur les particules dans
l'environnement intérieur ça veut dire
pour dire est-ce que vous est-ce que
c'est bien pas bien ou quels sont vos
objectifs à partir du moment où je peux
pas il est évident que c'est pas la RATP
même qui va faire son référentiel serait
jugé partie ça n'aurait pas de sens bon
raison pour laquelle les services de
l'État en saisit en ces
d'accord que cet agence a rendu c'est
récent en juin dernier
c'est son avis sur les résultats de son
expertise sur la qualité de l'air
précisément dans les enceintes
souterraines ferroviaires et elle a dit
en l'état des connaissances
scientifiques actuelles on ne peut pas
conclure sur des effets défavorables sur
la santé des voyageurs bon
de la même façon combien des plaintes
sans doute savez-vous monsieur le député
qui ont été déposés
er-parif autre organisme que je n'ai pas
besoin de présenter à votre commission à
du conduit une expertise qui a été
rendue elle s'est encore plus récent en
juillet dernier d'après les informations
qui m'ont été communiquées pour dire que
je cite le dispositif de surveillance
que nous avons mis avec la RATP pardon a
mis en place sur la qualité de l'air
était l'un des plus complets au monde
mais tout ça c'est bien c'est plutôt
enfin ça suffit peut-être pas
complètement ni à répondre à votre
question ni surtout à épuisé le sujet
donc c'est un point sur lequel il faut
impérativement progresser rassurer je
comprends qu'il y ait des qui est des
questionnements et encore une fois ça
fait partie du plan satellite donc je
veillerai ce que ça soit conduite
autre question sur les les
le plan bus 2025 est un des vous l'avez
dit d'ailleurs en plusieurs des leviers
forts de la politique de transition
énergétique de écologique de
l'entreprise
bon alors les enseignements précis c'est
vous je vous dise je les ai pas fait je
veux dire sur le bilan environnemental
ça doit exister mais je suis très
étalez-vous j'ai pas vous conditionnez
pas le président sortant de RATP mais
l'éventuel président entrant en tout cas
bon parce qu'on voit bien que évidemment
passer de bus diesel à des bus
électriques ou au biocarburant c'est ça
va forcément améliorer sensiblement
notre bilan carbone donc je m'engage à
vous donner des éléments dès que je les
aurais sur ce bilan précis qui existe
forcément en cours de route et je dis
que sur l'hydrogène parce que c'est le
cas ça c'est une des première question
est en très attachée à la stratégie
nationale que nous avons beaucoup
développée
j'ai compris qu'existait une
expérimentation de centre bus hydrogène
qui a été lancé par Île-de-France
mobilité je crois que c'est à Bagneux et
à
valerçu du Grand Paris c'est ça donc je
ne connais pas par construction encore
les résultats de cette expérience mais
oui nous avons intérêt et notamment pour
la région que vous dites c'est à dire
c'est une entreprise comme la RATP
s'engage sur ce créneau ça a une valeur
qui la dépasse si je puis m'exprimer
ainsi ou en tout cas reprendre vos
propos donc il faut le faire voilà
je reviens sur un sujet donc toujours
environnemental qui est sur la la
publicité
est-ce que m'a demandé publicité
électronique est-ce que vous vous
engagez à mettre fin d'un coup comme ça
bon non ce serait pas raisonnable de ma
part je vois c'est parce que vous
souhaitez en tout cas ce que je peux
vous dire Madame non mais pas d'un coup
comme ça les choses ne marchent pas
comme ça
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que il y
a un programme déjà pour diminuer les
émissions visuelles
pour passer à dud à chaque fois que
possible
et pour limiter tous les impacts
environnementaux de ces publicités bon
il y a déjà un plan qui était qui est en
cours qui est développé par l'entreprise
je suis pas en mesure de vous dire ce
matin un s'il est comment dire
pleinement efficace deux s'il est
suffisant et dans quel mesure ou dans
quelle proportion il faut l'améliorer
mon objectif en tant que futur chef
d'entreprise c'est effectivement de pas
si je peux avoir des recettes là-dessus
je moi je crache pas bien sûr mais
évidemment il faut qu'elle soit
compatible avec avec les exigences
environnementales donc plutôt que de
dire j'arrête tout bon effectivement
mais je pense que là aussi par la
technologie par le recours à de nouveaux
moyens on peut avoir de la publicité et
donc les recettes affaires et un impact
environnemental significativement
diminué en tout cas c'est mon objectif
pas vous dire aujourd'hui ce qu'il en
est mais en tout cas le sujet est connu
dans l'entreprise parce que dans les
documents que j'ai consulté il était il
est apparu
sans le liège j'ai eu plusieurs
questions d'ailleurs on avait une tout à
l'heure sur l'autre monsieur Bricout sur
Lafitte bon c'est à dire que c'est
intéressant parce que
même si on veut pas me nommer à la RATP
c'est pas en raison de mon incompétence
et ça et c'est parce que j'étais très
bien à la fille bon
oui non on habitait je parle pas de
votre question à vous je vais bon
mon bilan à la fuite il est
effectivement court maigre ça je vois
mais bon c'est pas moi de le dresser
quand même les amis mais je les
honorable parlementaires ici présente à
ceux qui s'occupent de la fuite sans le
chargeront je les y invite je suis pas
sûr qu'ils soient complètement nul bon
j'ai déjà stabilisé un peu les effectifs
on a voté un nombre de conventions très
important dans peu de moi on va avoir un
taux d'exécution budgétaire encore
amélioré bon
c'est un établissement public c'est pas
tout à fait une agence vous savez la
fiche c'est un établissement de l'État
je répète
que sa grande force c'est de rassembler
à un seul lieu organiquement distinct
différentes sources de financement et de
les préserver un peu de la régulation
budgétaire c'est peut-être pas
complètement orthodoxe on s'en était
déjà expliqué mais encore une fois ce
qui est devant le pays
c'est un mur d'investissement monsieur
le Président du coi j'espère que le
service sera ambitieux bien sûr pour
l'Île-de-France mais chacun comprendra
dans ma bouche pas que pour
l'Île-de-France sur ce sujet et donc on
est des relais qui effectivement ne
doivent pas être des coquilles vides
pour
[Musique]
être le réceptacle des politiques
publiques me paraît une solution adaptée
je l'ai dit et je le et je le répète et
deux des quelques semaines que j'ai
passé à la tête du conseil
d'administration de cet agent ou siège
des parlementaires
j'ai pu mesurer que on peut avoir une
utilité réelle à cet outil il faudra
amplifier je n'ai pas idée de qui me
remplacera à cette à la tête de cet
agent j'en profite pour informer les
députés qu'évidemment
si le Parlement ne s'oppose pas à ma
nomination l'acte suivant sera ma
nomination au CA de la RATP dans un
premier temps et
concomitamment évidemment il sera mis
fin à mes fonctions de président de
l'Agence de financement des
infrastructures de transport tout à fait
logique il possible de cumuler ces deux
fonctions mais je ne doute pas en tout
cas de la volonté du gouvernement de
veiller à me désigner un successeur ou
une successeur rapidement et
qui
poursuivra ce qui a été engagé je répète
je dis aussi à Monsieur Brico ça nous
donne des trucs les plus efficients
parce que encore une fois l'équipe est
très réduite et je la salue au passage
parce que le travail qui est fait on
peut pas dire en tout cas dans le
panorama des agences établissent en vie
que vous avez dressé que ce soit celui
qui soit le plus consommateur de moyens
de fonctionnement ou comme on dit de
frais de structure
alors je
regarde oui alors il y a des questions
combien il me reste monsieur le
président
vous avez tout le temps ah si vous avez
tout le temps
ce qui compte c'est que la
représentation nationale soit éclairée
absolument alors sur le niveau de
service
qui rejoint plus généralement
l'actif de la RATP ce niveau service
donc vous avez maintenant les chaussons
claires un la présence d'idfm a annoncé
qu'on reviendrait à un service qu'on va
revenir un service complet alors
maintenant la balle est effectivement
complètement dans le camp de la RATP
pour pouvoir
cette exigence et à la fois lutter
contre l'absentéisme et procédé à des
recrutements s'il vous plaît chers
collègues est-ce que il y a juste 10
secondes je disais que la représentation
nationale devait être éclairée si on
peut juste terminer dans le silence
merci
c'est le premier ministre pardon voilà
donc
le temps IDFM que la RATP ont pris toute
une série de mesures soit pour lutter
contre l'accentéisme soit pour recruter
des gens j'observe d'après encore une
fois les données qui me sont
communiquées que effectivement le rythme
des recrutements s'accélère tant dans le
bus que sur le métro bon encore une fois
ça va pas je n'ai pas de baguette
magique et ça peut pas se faire du jour
au lendemain d'autant je le répète que
la RATP n'est pas le seul secteur en
tension au niveau des recrutements ayant
du mal à pourvoir ses postes mais en
tout cas je ne peux que répéter à
l'Assemblée nationale ce que j'ai dit
hier au Sénat mon rôle sera un de
m'assurer que les outils déployés tant
par IDFM que par la RATP le dernier en
date étant le recours à l'intérim sont
effectivement mis en œuvre
et de voir le résultat et d'essayer je
me suis donné pour ça qu'un jour trois
semaines c'est j'en ai bien conscience
l'urgence absolue d'essayer de voir s'il
y a lieu de trouver des leviers
complémentaires pour soit faire revenir
au travail des agents qui n'y sont pas
qui sont déjà dans l'entreprise soit
pour accroître les recrutoires mais
encore une fois je rappelle qu'il y a
aussi des procédures
pas simplement ça en procédural mais
quand vous recrutez par des conducteurs
de bus il y a du criblage enfin il y a
des
pas c'est pas quelqu'un quand le recrute
tout de suite on le met son travail à
des formations préalables donc il y a
nécessairement un temps entre l'acte de
recrutement lui-même et le fait que le
machiniste soit
dans son autobus en train de conduire
mais voilà c'est en tout cas évidemment
comme je vous l'ai déjà dit la priorité
j'ai c'est l'occasion pour moi de vous
dire ce que j'ai annoncé aussi au Sénat
hier c'est que il fallait aussi voir un
peu plus plus loin et me semble-t-il
tirer un retour d'expérience de ce qui
se passe maintenant je pense que nous
avons deux sujets là aussi qui
évidemment se traiteront par la
négociation qui est le premier celui de
la qualité de la vie au travail voilà
sûrement impacté par les questions
d'ouverture à conjura
mais sur lesquels nous devons faire un
travail au long cours là c'est pas de
répondre à l'urgence mais c'est
d'éclairer ces décisions de court terme
par des actions beaucoup plus
structurelles qui ont d'ailleurs été
commencé et puis montrer certains ont
parlé d'anticipation dans leurs
interventions
que ou essayer en tout cas d'avoir ou de
nous améliorer sur la gestion
prévisionnelle des emplois et des
compétences et qui est sans doute un
sujet de Fond le
les effectifs ou l'évolution des
effectifs quantitatifs de la RATP bon il
y a déjà le fait que qui est source de
qu'il va falloir mener avec doigté de
passer les effectifs de l'épique vers la
filiale pour les bus
dédiés à la réponse aux appels d'offres
à la concurrence
donc ça ça va faire diminuer par contre
par définition le nombre des effectifs
d'effectifs de tête encore une fois
je pense que 1 il faut poursuivre ce
qu'avait commencé ma prédécesseur c'est
à dire
essayer de limiter au maximum les
fonctions support ou les fonctions de
siège pour renvoyer des effectifs vers
les unités opérationnelles ça c'est
neutre point de vue
globale mais on a des impératifs en
termes de productivité aussi et encore
une fois après ça va dépendre des parts
de marché soit dans le cas ils appellent
la concurrent soit de la clientèle que
nous allons reconquérir dans les années
à venir c'est ça qui doit déterminer le
volume quantitatif de nos emplois et
effectivement il faut être ambitieux en
la matière
je regarde si j'ai oublié des
je peux
je le Premier ministre merci d'avoir
partagé votre ambition pour la RATP
je vous remercie du temps que vous nous
avez donné pour que l'ensemble des
collègues puisse s'exprimer nous allons
maintenant vous laisser partir de sorte
à ce que nous puissions procéder au vote
merci monsieur le Premier ministre